Ihr hört technik kultur gesellschaft mein name ist tim und ich sag hallo nach einer längeren pause auf diesem kanal.
Den die nicht kleinkriegen kann das kann ich euch sagen es wird immer weitergehen mit aber manchmal muss man auch mal ein bisschen nachdenken worüber man denn eigentlich so sprechen möchte.
Und.
Genau darüber geht's heute eigentlich auch heute bin ich mal ein bisschen in ein thema einsteigen was ich vielleicht am anfang gar nicht so richtig fassen lässt.
Nämlich über das sprechen und das kommunizieren.
Und was man damit eigentlich so bezweckt und was man damit so erreichen kann und auf welche art und weise man das vielleicht am besten erreichen kann.
Man könnte sagen wir sprechen über entsprechendes denken vielleicht findet sich auch noch ein anderer untertitel.
Aber erstmal begrüße ich mein gesprächspartner heute nehme ich den moritz moritz klink hallo moritz.
Hallo freut mich hier zu sein.
Freut mich auch sehr wir haben das auch schon längere zeit für uns hergeschoben ja jetzt haben wir endlich mal die zeit gefunden das ist gut müssen wir natürlich erstmal rauskriegen wer du eigentlich so bist.
Du bist ja bist du eigentlich philosoph kann man sagen oder.
Also wenn man sich so fachforen spezifisch immer zuordnet und vorstellen muss dann würde ich sagen ich habe kulturwissenschaften studiert also kultur wissenschaft.
Dann noch religionswissenschaften.
Ich habe in bayreuth und in edinburgh studiert und dann habe ich fast sechs jahre in der soziologie gearbeitet dort eine promotion begonnen.
Die ich dann mit nach bern genommen habe um nur dann quasi über diesen umweg in berlin in der kulturwissenschaftler zu landen und dort eine arbeit zu schreiben das heißt ich würde sagen ich bin kulturwissenschaftler,
ja kulturwissenschaftler und mit.
Zumindest schwerpunktmäßig philosophischen interessen.
Und warum bist du das geworden.
Wieso vieles ist das.
Vermutlich zufall und dann aber auch so eine gewisse art von faszination die man oder die zumindest ich leicht entwickelt wenn ich mich intensiv mit themen beschäftigen und.
Und und dann gibt's eben so ganz oder gar nicht
so kam ich zu fächern also man liest texte und manche interessieren ein und man fasziniert sich für theorien für ansätze für fragen wie welt eigentlich beschrieben werden kann und warum das.
Kultur wissenschaftlich beschrieben werden müsste also warum das eine interessante perspektive ist.
Warum gesellschaft und kultur.
So referenzen sind die die alles nachdenken letztlich in irgendeiner form.
Prägen in einer form dass es lohnt das zu verstehen so genau es gibt noch sehr viele abwege die man jetzt noch diskutieren könnte und gründe warum man das so aber.
Aber.
Wann hast du denn damit angefangen also ich meine wann wann ist das hast du bist du schon so so eine so ein so ein so ein buch leser mit fünf jahren gewesen oder bist du da ja so ein spät entwickler.
Sozusagen das hängt dann immer erfolgreiche professorinnen und professoren erzählen dann wie sie dann mit fünf das erste mal schiller gelesen habe und so und ich habe ich nicht.
Ich wollte ursprünglich wollte ich mal musik studieren ich habe auch also ich habe mich viel für musik interessiert.
Und das wollte ich eigentlich studieren und ich kam durch zufall zu der kultur wissenschaft das ich habe nach einem studium gesucht und das schien interessante beschreibung zu sein und ich habe keine ahnung davon.
Bist du ein instrument.
Das ist natürlich gleich.
Also ich spiele ich habe konzerthaus studiert.
Quasi in der schule ja genau also ich habe das das habe ich gelernt das ist mein hauptinstrument damit habe ich auch abitur gemacht.
Damit damit war es auf jeden fall schon mal der in der klasse oder.
Also das gibt es gab nicht viele jungs die das gemacht haben ja.
Ja auch ein bisschen aufwärmen mit seiner konzert haben in der straßenbahn unterwegs ist.
Ja also mein papa damals gesagt ich sollte doch lieber flöte lernen er müsste sich jetzt wegen mir ein neues auto kaufen aber ich glaube das war nur ein vorwand.
Er müsste sich warum harfe.
Das waren wieder zufälle es gab eine ausschreibung meine eltern sind fans von irischer volksmusik.
Es gab eine ein aushang das hafenunternehmer angeboten wird mein vater fand das großartig ich war sechs jahre alt und leicht zu beeindrucken
ich bin einfach mit gegangen weil ich also mit sechs hat man keine wahl wo man hingeht oder nicht und ich musste also mit und dachte ah das ist ja ein interessantes gerät
das könnte ich doch auch mal ausprobieren und habe gesagt dass mich auch ausbau.
Sechsjährigen als ziemlich.
Es gibt auch kleine also es gibt kleine man fängt mit einer kleinen have an.
Und so einen stand da rum.
Und da standen ganz viele rum die haben das tatsächlich die hatten so viele die haben die verkauft.
Und dann habe ich angefangen mich damit zu beschäftigen und irgendwann.
Wurde das mehr also man kann da tolle sachen drauf machen jetzt sind momentan ist es leider schon längere zeit liegt da so ein bisschen.
Hast du deine hafen nicht dabei.
Ich habe sie nicht ständig dabei sowieso nicht aber momentan auch nicht also ich wohne jetzt in bern und da ist so eine räumlichkeiten sehr beschränkt,
die schweiz teuer und so sagt mir gerne.
Nehmen wir das mal als begründung und deswegen steht die momentan nicht darum ich habe eine reihe anderer instrumente also es soll ja nicht langweilig werden aber.
Verstehe aber trotzdem bist du dann irgendwann auf diesen wissenschaftlichen zug aufgesprungen.
Nein also ich habe schon gern gelesen und das irgendwann wieder zwischendrin verloren und dann mich für andere dinge interessiert und dann irgendwann wieder angefangen zu lesen und mit dem studium begann eigentlich wirklich erst so richtig mein interesse für.
Für all diese fragen führung philosophische fragen für wissenschafts- theoretische fragen für die frage wie kommen wir eigentlich zur erkenntnis was ist das überhaupt erkenntnis und diese faszination für theorie und methoden also für tatsächlich,
wissenschaftliche reflexion von wissenschaftlicher erkenntnis dass das war was mich interessiert hat.
Zusätzlich zu den verschiedenen gegenständen der einzelnen disziplin war das aber.
Das ist schon eine ziemliche meter frage eigentlich.
Ja das ist das ist dann die frage ob das eine meter frage ist oder ob nicht.
Ob nicht die frage nach der erkenntnis möglichkeit in jedem ganz konkreten gegenstand selbst mit verhandelt werden muss.
Also ich weiß dass die meisten disziplinen oder vertreterinnen und vertreter von disziplin in der regel interessiert sind an ihren jeweils ganz konkreten gegenständen und jetzt sagen die frage nach der möglichkeit von erkenntnis.
Einem gewissen grad zumindest für beantwortet halten.
Also man hat sich darüber verständigt wie man zur erkenntnis kommt und jetzt beschäftigen wir uns damit wie man zur erkenntnis von etwas kommt gegenständen irgendwelchen phänomen.
Meines erachtens ist das allerdings nur wechselseitig vermittelt überhaupt zu denken also man kann nicht.
Sowohl kann man nicht über erkenntnis ganz abstrakt und allgemein nachdenken wenn dann ist das auch eine konkrete frage oder es muss als eine ganz konkrete frage behandelt werden.
Noch kann man über zwangsläufig einfach so über irgendwelche gegenstände nachdenken und denken ja die frage mit der erkenntnis dass es was das machen die philosophen oder philosophie nen.
Hallo
kann man schon so behandeln und auch erfolgreiche karrieren in der wissenschaft dadurch verfolgen aber meines erachtens wird das falsch also es wird erkenntnistheoretisch tatsächlich falsch das bezugs problem von wissenschaftlicher erkenntnis ist immer die möglichkeit von erkenntnis.
Was jetzt war schon schon gleich.
Also punkt angekommen will ich nochmal kurz nochmal eine bremse einlegen weil da werden wir auf jeden fall hinkommen.
Wissenschaft ist wie würdest du das beschreiben was was dort erforscht wird.
Ja das ist,
das ist gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten die frage weil kulturwissenschaften
im singular als einzelne disziplin kann man sagen hat mehrere disziplinäre hintergründe beschäftigt sich mit kultur phänomen im weiteren sinne je nachdem was der kultur begriff ist also ist die wissenschaft von kultur so einfach gesagt
kulturwissenschaften im plural ist die mittlerweile fast gängiger bezeichnung für das was ehemals geisteswissenschaften hieß
und dann aber sagen mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts so verschiedene sogenannte cultural turns na durchlaufen hat
also verschiedene wendungen selbstreflektive wendungen dann hatten das hat alle disziplinen betroffen also nicht nur die technologie von der viele impulse ausgängen sondern auch die sprachwissenschaftler die philosophie die soziologie alle möglichen anderen disziplinen die sich im weitesten sinne noch damit dazu gezählt haben
wenn sie sich nicht also unter dem label der sozialwissenschaften davon irgendwie distanzieren.
Oder distanziert wurden je nachdem das heißt,
kulturwissenschaften ist das
im plural ist das was man geisteswissenschaften nennen kann und beschäftigt sich dann sagen in dem ganzen spektrum von sprache über philosophie geschichte.
Kultur phänomene ethnologie also sozial und kultur logie heißt es im wesentlichen heute mit allen möglichen leben phänomen dass das sagen menschlichen der menschlichen gesellschaft
und kultur also so so.
Was menschen so treiben und denken.
Ja ja genau also so und der singular kulturwissenschaften im singular ist für mich deswegen,
auch nochmal ganz spezielle möglichkeit als sein als diskurs kontext sich spezifisch diesen fragen der der.
Der kultur der eben dieses dieser bedingungen des.
Sowohl des sozialen als auch eben der vielfalt der symbol systeme des der deutung systeme und so weiter der ganzen des ganzen reichtums der kulturellen produktion von menschen sich,
auseinanderzusetzen und dafür hat man sein einfach dass es so vielseitig wie weniger fächer.
Das heißt das da lag auch dein schwerpunkt.
Ja also schwerpunkt mein schwerpunkt ist würde ich sagen er theorie also kulturwissenschaftler theorie oder ja.
Mich haben immer schon theorien interessiert oder theorie fragen also wie beschreibe ich das sagen in so einem systematischen zusammenhang ich bin mit da einem
speziellen interesse das system theorie in dieser theorie fragen reingerutscht system theorie im anschluss an.
Den deutschen soziologen niklas lohmann der
die theorie ist verschrien für besonders komplexe differenzierte,
begrifflichkeiten sie gilt manchmal manchen als hermetisch
das ist so ein bisschen quatsch aber
ja also es ist auf jeden fall eine sehr laborierte theorie die nach wie vor von vielen für eine sehr anspruchsvolle theorie gehalten wird
und über diese theorie fragen bin ich quasi mit mit solchen
mit diesem phänomen konfrontiert worden oder mit ja genau mit kultur und kultur und auch die
treten natürlich tauchen im gegenstand bereich der kulturwissenschaften auf also kulturwissenschaften selber hat sich auch zum selbst zum gegenstand dieses selbstreflektive verwendung
ist er den kulturwissenschaften wie wenigen anderen disziplinen meines erachtens ganz besonders ein besonderes merkmal.
Weil man zwangsläufig so systemisch denken muss weil man sozusagen überhaupt das feld erstmal strukturiert bekommen muss bevor man anfangen kann darüber nachzudenken.
Die zugänge könnten ganz also unterschiedlich formuliert werden aber vielleicht meiner oder ein meinen zugang ist.
Das alles was wir über welt wissen wie wir über welt sprechen denken alles was wir wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse im.
Ganz konkreten aber auch im weitesten sinne nennen können ist immer gesellschaftlich und kulturell vermittelt,
wir haben nie einen anderen zugang wir sprechen immer mit sprache über dinge die wir wissenschaftlich erforschen und wir können noch die tollsten maschinen bauen wenn wir das hinterher nicht in wissenschaftliche sprache fassen können wenn wir darüber uns nicht verständigen können und diese sprache ist immer kulturell und
gesellschaftlich geprägt vermittelt die es nichts anderes oder umgekehrt auch,
gesellschaft und kultur ist in dieser form sinn förmig also hat im medium sinn und es sprachformen medium sprache verhandelt miteinander verhandelt,
man hat also immer nur diesen zugang und da mögen sich andere disziplinen sagen in bestimmten zugängen
das anders vorstellen oder meistens davon absehen wenn man maschinen geräte baut mit denen man die welt untersucht und mist etwa und dann.
Computer passiert modelle entwickelt die dann wieder etwas sagen dann kann man kurz für einen moment vergessen dass das alles sprachlich konstruiert ist,
aber eben halt nur für einen moment und im nächsten fällt das wieder auf und kulturwissenschaftlerin fällt das würde ich sagen immer auf.
Das heißt ihr ihr untersucht oder du und da hast du zumindest untersucht oder dir darüber gedanken gemacht.
Wie kommuniziere ich überhaupt und wie denke ich über die dinge nach und wie komme ich.
Überhaupt erst in die situation daraus ein schluss ziehen zu können und diesen auch als solchen vermitteln zu können.
Hallo.
Ja die frage nach der erkenntnis also das ist dass das tatsächlich die frage die da die du die du damit stellt die frage nach der erkenntnis möglichkeit ist eine die die philosophie also und damit eigentlich
die wissenschaften im ganzen schon immer interessiert hat die frage wie kommt man zu eigentlich zu einer erkenntnis von der welt
und dass das sprachlich vermittelt stattfindet.
Ist dann schon wieder so ein eher spezifischer zuschnitt oder kann auch als eine position als eine position innerhalb dieser wissenschaftlichen ansätze sich darüber auch selbst wieder zu verständigen verstanden werden
aber ja das ist das was mich interessiert also kommunikations passierte kommunikation passiert konstruktion von weltweit zugänge
symbolische zugänge sinnhafte zugänge welche formen entstehen dabei welche formen werden dabei konstruiert und so weiter und so fort also das sind.
Das ist das was mich interessiert und gerade im hinblick auf eben diese
konkrete vermittlung von allen gegenständen im ganz konkreten sei es jetzt ein protestmarsch.
Einer politischen bewegung sei es ein ein kunstwerk im kontext der aktuellen kunst debatten sei es sei es irgendein
und uns heißt ein ein kometen einschlag auf einem planeten fern von unserem von dem man jetzt irgendwas erfahren haben sollte oder so
all diese phänomene haben gemeinsam das darüber gesprochen und wird in einer form die die uns die frage nach der wie kommen wir zur erkenntnis diese frage einfach immer wieder aufdrängen.
Das heißt ja dann eigentlich auch dass man sich erstmal wenn man das wirklich versucht umfangreich zu analysieren sich darüber gedanken machen muss wie diese sprache an sich.
Entstanden ist und wenn man jetzt mal die erkenntnisse oder die
gemessenen daten zum beispiel aus der evolution theorie herbei nimmt so dann besagt es
ja wir waren mal so wie alle anderen tiere auch oder vielleicht die vier,
aber irgendwie kann man wenn man so immer mal wieder so zehntausend jahre weiter zurückgeht,
kommt man halt auf irgend so ein uhr menschen und man kann halt.
Vermuten dadurch dass man ja auch andere entwicklungs- die aus einem ähnlichen stamm hervorgegangen sind wenn man wenn man schaut wie es wie es denn so gegangen ist stellt man fest.
Sprache haben die nicht zumindest nicht in der form wie wir sie haben ja also wird jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen gorillas haben keine sprache.
Ich weiß jetzt wenn ich über gorillas aber meine vermutung ist sie haben auf jeden fall auch ihre eigenen abstraktion.
Die kommunizieren auch abstrakt sind ja auch in der lage wenn man sich so.
Und so weiter all diese ganzen
affen forscher primaten forscher anschaut so die ja auch in der lage sind mit diesen tieren in eine kommunikation zu treten und gerade so in den letzten zehn zwanzig jahren,
so die erkenntnis gereift sogar tiere sind wahrscheinlich auch alle intelligenter als wir immer dachten so man kann irgendwie nicht nur mit papageien reden sondern man kann irgendwie auch so den raben dabei zuschauen wie sie komplexe lösungen finden und in der lage sind auf dinge zu reagieren.
Die wir vielleicht so vorher noch gar nicht gesehen haben nur eben diese konkrete form der sprache wie wir sie eben pflegen so ist verhältnismäßig selten.
Aber auch die muss ich ja alle muss ja auch erstmal entwickelt haben und wenn du darüber nachdenkst wie sich das entwickelt hat muss ja.
Ich muss ja erstmal einen anlass gegeben haben und das hat ja wahrscheinlich auch viel mit erkenntnis.
Die welt zu tun also die erstmal die die fähigkeit zur abstrahieren.
Dinge überhaupt erstmal zu unterscheiden ja klar zu sagen so das ist ein baum und die fängt er an und da hört er auf so und das ist etwas anderes als etwas als als das was ich jetzt hier habe.
Das ist ja das was dann im gehirn überhaupt erst auf dem bedarf schafft diese symbole und damit im worte dafür zu finden bezeichnung zu finden denn.
Wenn ich die nicht habe kann ich ja auch nicht darüber.
Kommunizieren sage ich jetzt mal reden es vielleicht schon der nächste schritt so auch wenn ich nur auf irgendwas zeige oder durch irgendeine körper berührung oder irgendein grund laut versuche auf irgendwas hinzuweisen muss es ja irgendwie sein was.
Ich weiß nicht ob sie sich aber überhaupt beschäftigt hat mir fällt das jetzt einfach gerade so ein.
Was sozusagen hier ursache und folge eigentlich ist also was kann der auslöser gewesen sein dafür.
Ja also zu zu theorie der entstehung von sprache oder sprach möglichkeit und dann notwendigkeit und so da gibt's natürlich umfangreiche radtour zu und disziplin die sich damit befassen auch jetzt
primaten forschung mag noch ein anderer zweig sein etwas mit dem man sich.
Auch noch also aktuell ganz neue erkenntnisse hier neulich eine podcast-folge gehört ich habe leider den namen vergessen den titel auch wo es genau um diese frage ging der der sprachfähigkeit auch wie
was für einen umfangreichen wortschatz beispielsweise können tiere entwickeln manche tiere und verstehen also tatsächlich verstehen und auch
darauf zeigen verwenden wörter auch wenn sie sie nicht aussprechen können aber.
Tatsächlich dann zumindest worte verwenden
bei menschen ist das natürlich sehr viel größer und umfangreicher als bei allen tieren die wir von denen wir das wissen.
Aber
das sind sehr interessante fragen keine kein zweifel aber für mich die in vielen interessantere beobachtung ist eigentlich die dass wir immer mittendrin anfangen
dass wir also nicht notwendig um jetzt uns.
Darüber verständigen zu können oder zu verstehen zu lernen wie wir uns,
mit der welt beschäftigen.
Wir menschen.
Okay nicht für kulturwissenschaftler.
Ja nicht genau wie wir menschen wie wir uns wieder ein welt zugang entwickeln.
Das was wir mittendrin.
Genau also da ist jetzt nicht notwendig um das zu verstehen es ist nicht notwendig zu verstehen wie kamen wir überhaupt zu sprache,
interessant auch
aber es ist meines erachtens nicht notwendig weil wir sagen in diese gesellschaft in diese welt die bereits sprache kennt die bereits sprache kennt und sich sprachlich auch die welt aneignet
die welt ist sagen selbst sprachlich verändert modifiziert und so weiter das heißt wir wir werden in dieses
in diese ganze welt die all das schon kennt hineingeboren wir müssen nicht mehr so tun als müssten wir noch einen anfangen zurückkämma genieren sondern wir beginnen bereits quasi mit sprache um uns herum.
Ja gut aber unser aktueller stand muss ja auch nicht das ende sein also wir haben jetzt nur eine gewisse vorstellung davon wie wir kommunizieren wie wir abstrahieren,
auch wenn man gerade so in der aktuellen politischen zeit so ein bisschen das gefühl hat dass wir in so einer rückentwicklung uns befinden oder zumindest in so einer entwicklungsphase so so sonst sonst und denk mittelalter was irgendwie auf einmal
einzieht ist es sicherlich jetzt keine zu gewagte these zu sagen das kann auch sein.
Dass wenn man sich jetzt die menschheit noch mal ein paar hundert jahre oder tausend jahre wenn sie's überhaupt noch schafft soweit vorstellt ja
dass auch unsere kommunikationsform.
Noch mehr effizienz haben als es jetzt schon haben im vergleich zu irgendeinem grunzen im walde zumindest ja dass dass ich daraus ja auch eine ganz andere art und weise der kommunikation vielleicht daraus eben auch eine ganz andere art und weise von logik
erkenntnisse etcetera entwickeln kann also kein also es ist natürlich richtig wenn du sagst ich
ich bin da jetzt rein geboren und das ist das womit ich jetzt arbeite aber das galt ja für die menschen vor zehntausend jahren im prinzip genauso nur dass sie da sozusagen mit weniger haben arbeiten müssen weil was weiß ich das hirn sich noch nicht so weit entwickelt hat
oder eben diese sprache sich auch kulturell noch nicht so weit entwickelt hat und sich ja permanent immer wieder ändert aber die anforderungen waren ja dann auch immer noch die.
Die gleichen dieses
diese suche nach symbolen nach bedeutungen nach einer abstraktion dann eben so dass ich ein ein passenden begriff verwende um irgendwo etwas korrekt beschreiben zu können
gepaart mit der notwendigkeit andere leute auch auf denselben auf dieselbe kommunikationsebene zu heben.
Ja ich meine soziologisch beispielsweise soziologisch medien
historisch und medien theoretisch kann man ja da unter anderem was jetzt gerade die entwicklung der kommunikationsmöglichkeiten angeht zumindest so ganz markante einschnitte
beobachten einmal natürlich die erfindung der sprache im unterschied zu kunst lauten und dem zeigen,
spielweise aber dann auch die erfindung der schrift.
Also die die das von dir das zu sagen aufzeichnen macht in einer weise wie es vorher nicht da war
und dann aber auch als nächste nächste einschnitt zu sagen der buchdruck mitbewegt
lettern also das einfache setzen und die massenhafte reproduktion von geschriebenen texten die dann sagen die reichweite extrem,
und also extrem erweitert und dadurch aber auch nicht nur die reichweite und verbreitung sondern ganz neue formate ermöglicht hat die dann entstehen konnten unter solchen bedingungen der verbreitung medien evolution
und dann letztlich heute die
entdeckungen und erfindung und entwicklung elektronischer kommunikation und computer passiert da kommunikation und das sozusagen also vier ganz ganz
markante einschnitte der der entwicklung von kommunikationsmöglichkeiten zu begreifen da ist da wird viel auch an gesellschafts- theoretischen annahmen daran herumgeschraubt.
Dirk becker beispielsweise ist einer der sich viel damit beschäftigt bei dem ich lange gearbeitet habe als assistent
der soziologe und beschäftigt sich unter anderem eben genau mit diesen medien revolution und diesen medien wechseln.
Ich würde ja noch noch ein fünftes modell reinschmeißen in den mix mathematik.
Ja
Ja also mathematik formalisieren in in so einer entwicklung fällt würde ich sagen ja deutlich vor dieser jüngste erfindung der elektronischen kommunikation ob man
hier von einer sprache in dem sinne sprechen kann oder von einem kommunikationsmedium in diesem sinne das ist allerdings.
Wenn man sprache als abstraktion als aktion abstraktion begreift spielt natürlich mathematik schon eine rolle.
Ist die frage ob man das ob man das kann also man kann sicherlich es sprache immer auch oder es kann immer auch abstraktion betreffen zugleich aber abstraktion also im sinne von dem
verallgemeindernden zugriff zu etwas bestimmungen kriterien kategorien bildung und sofort
und der der kommunikativen aus aushandlung eben dessen was wir unter bestimmten kategorien begriffen label und namen und so weiter verstehen.
Können zugleich aber ist ist das ja nicht immer nur notwendig.
Abstrakt sondern auch sehr konkret also die sprache erlaubt es ja auch sehr sehr konkrete beschreibungen von phänomenen dies ein die einzigartig sind anzufertigen inwiefern das dann immer notwendig quasi die,
die idee der abstraktion
hier maßgeblich ist das würde ich zumindest in frage stellen also es klar es gibt so einen abstraktion prozesse die auch eine rolle spielen bei der genese von wörtern wortbedeutung und sofort aber es geht nicht nur um abstraktion sondern es geht,
wenn es um erkenntnis geht oder um die frage nach der erkenntnis geht dann geht es um sehr ganz konkrete fragen also um ganz konkrete phänomene.
So und diese spannung zwischen dem allgemeinen und dem ganz konkreten oder eben auch im hinblick auf abstraktion aber auch wortneuschöpfung
mediale entwicklungen die es einmal lauben da ganz andere zugriffe zu stellen zu finden zu entwickeln zu experimentieren auch mit solchen anderen zugriffen dass es was was mich unter anderem sehr interessiert hat und auch in meinen letzten arbeiten interessiert hat also
wenn man sich anschaut.
Dass wir beispielsweise im alltag sprachlichen oft eben mündlich kommunizieren im wissenschafts sprachlichen allerdings als wissenschaftliche erkenntnis nur zählt was geschrieben ist
in vor allem hauptsächlich in journal beiträgen in peer-review journal beiträgen also den beiträgen die von kolleginnen und kollegen
blind ohne dass man weiß wer das geschrieben hat eben begutachtet werden und dann überarbeitet und so weiter und dann als wissenschaftliche erkenntnis zählen weil sie eben in einem solchen fach in einer solchen fachzeitschrift erscheinen können,
oder eben in monografisch wissenschaftlichen arbeiten oder in qualifikationen schriften und so weiter aber auf jeden fall in geschriebener form,
es gibt natürlich konferenzen es gibt formen wie wir uns über wissenschaftliche kommunikation noch,
machen auch in der mündlichen art und weise wir haben seminare und vorlesungen an universitäten wird viel gesprochen aber so richtig als wissenschaftliche erkenntnis zählt
fast nur was geschrieben steht und das ist nicht meines erachtens gar nicht.
Notwendig das hat sich entwickelt.
Bevor wir dann in dem bereich forschung noch mal ganz gerne so ein bisschen vielleicht bin ich da ein bisschen verbohrt aber mich mich fasziniert dieser
gedanke oder diese überlegung was sozusagen der der treibende faktor für diese weiterentwicklung der sprache auch ist jetzt hast du ja gesagt okay
abstraktion später auf jeden fall erstmal eine rolle oder ist in gewisser hinsicht vielleicht eher so eine voraussetzung sozusagen also das das hirn ist ausreichend erlagen dinge so komplex wahrzunehmen um daraus eben eine abstraktion zu machen sei es jetzt die abstraktion der bildlichen beschreibung ja hier ein baum hier ein strauch hier ein ufer etcetera
oder eben auch in mathematischer hinsicht und auch so die schrift weil am anfang auch oft
mathematik insofern als dass man einfach erstmal strich rechnung gemacht hat dinge gezählt hat und daran ja quasi aus einer abstraktion weiterentwickelt hat.
Ich frage mich nur was ist jetzt der treibende faktor für die weiterentwicklung der sprache.
Ist das zimmer da schon sozusagen bei erkenntnis erlangung so es ist einfach etwas was zwangsläufig passiert wenn man es viel.
Benutzt was denkst du ist der antrieb in der weiterentwicklung unserer kommunikation ist das.
Was man so versteht von der welt.
Also ich ich will sagen dass auf einen einzigen faktor zu bringen es vollkommen unmöglich aber auch gar nicht so notwendig weil weil sprache entwickelt sich in,
wie du sagst in der verwendung in der benutzung von sprache verändert sich sprache,
das ist einmal zu lang auch schon auf was
grammatik angeht oder die erfindung neuer wörter die die regeln des mündlichen schriftlich und so weiter kommunizieren ist das alles entwickelt sich aber auch natürlich der reichtum von sprache die die konkrete,
verwendungszweck zusammenhänge was heute verständlich ist muss nicht immer so verstanden worden sein oder überhaupt verstanden werden können und umgekehrt was einmal verständlich war und vollkommen normaler satz ist heute wenig anschlussfähigen und es
entwickelt sich ständig fort aufgrund einfach der sein dass das vollkommen,
unberechenbaren unvorhersehbaren varianten reichtums von gesellschaftliche entwicklung von kultureller entwicklung das ist einfach
ein nie aufhörenden zu stellen der entwicklung die so in in ganz unvorhersehbarer art.
Sich evolutionär entwickelt sein und.
Dann fragen zu stellen wie das ganz konkret sich vollzieht an einzelnen fällen beispielsweise so studien unternehmen,
das wären dann mögliche sehr interessante forschungsfragen die auch unternommen werden sich,
an ganz konkreten fällen das anzusehen wie sich da sprache sprach veränderungen sprach benutzung verändert und sowas aufzuzeigen an konkreten phänomen aber eben
einen konkreten phänomen.
Jetzt hat der das sprechen auch besonders angetan ist ja auch irgendwann mal mit dem podcasting zusammengestoßen wie lange ist das jetzt schon her ist auch schon eine weile unterwegs in dem feld ne.
Ein paar jahre sind's schon ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau ich glaube also gehört habe ich schon ewig und angefangen glaube ich habe ich weiß ich nicht.
Zweitausendvierzehn oder ich weiß nicht mehr genau sind noch nicht so unendlich lange her aber es ist schon sind schon ein paar jahre genau.
Ja also zum podcasten kam ich mit dem mit dem hören letztlich also der erste zugang zu podcast es war für mich wie für die meisten einhören da oder weiß ich nicht nicht für die meisten aber,
für viele dann doch ein hören dazu gang,
und dann aber sofort die faszination für ständig reden die davon das sei so einfach das kann jeder machen und so dass mich das will ich mal wissen.
Wir wissen heißt in dem fall eben machen können also so ganz konkret das war sofort dieser diese notwendige zugang das das muss ich ausprobieren muss ich basteln können muss ich muss ich selber mal ausprobieren,
von anfang bis ende also wie wie wie nehme ich das auf.
Und wie so oft ist es auch also ich kenne das jetzt von vielen diese geschichte dass wie so oft an.
Die die technischen fragen zu anfang standen und die frage worüber ich eigentlich sprechen will die kam halt irgendwann also was kümmere ich mich dann jetzt.
Nehmen wir erst mal ein aufnahme-gerät und dann schaue ich mal wie das mit der aufnahme funktioniert und dann fällt mir schon was ein worüber ich sprechen kann so und so waren meine ersten podcast auch also ich hatte natürlich auch ideen worüber ich sprechen könnte.
Aber die stellen sich meistens als irrtümer heraus oder man spricht dann doch immer was ganz anderes.
Und so auch mit den ersten podcast projekten die ich dann unternommen hatte und dann hatte ich hauptsächlich podcasts mit
mit freunden und kollegen in der schweiz ich habe damals noch in deutschland gewohnt aber das ist ja kein hindernis mehr wo man ist.
War das war das dann diese radio-show mit der du angefangen hast.
Ja genau also es hieß früher neunzehnachtundsechzig kritik,
weil es ging um so eine kritik der altachtundsechziger praktisch die versagt haben politisch und überhaupt also die die revolution zum greifen nah hatten und dann
versagt hatten so zumindest war mal die ursprüngliche idee und wir haben dann über alles mögliche gerettet vor allem nur zum beispiel medien wechsel die veränderung
politischer kommunikation wissenschaftlicher kommunikation künstlerischer kontexte sozialer
kontexte im weiteren sinne und so weiter durch die erfindung von computern und vernetzten rechnern insbesondere und dann
die themen bandbreite ist also demnach unendlich.
Genau aber mit diesen podcast habe ich dann begonnen und.
Warum hier ist es dann radio-show.
Später ist es nur radioshow weil es ist eben nicht radio sondern podcast und die unterscheidung war mir die leuchtete mir immer ein
dass man keine sendezeit hat
dass man keine redaktion hat dass man das alles selber ist dass man das dass es technisch weniger aufwendig ist dass ich diese professionalisierung in einer gewissen weise auch auf distanz halten kann und mir dieses schmutzige einfache diesen sofort improvisierten und experimentelle zugang einfach dadurch
erhalte indem ich dieses dieses diesen radio begriff der ja doch.
Schon mit gewisse vorbelastung hat
nicht nur historisch politische vorbelastung sondern auch so eine professionelle vorbelastung hat auf distanz halten kann und aber auch weil es nicht notwendig ums händen geht
also ich weiß es gibt
auch sendung sein als als begriff in der podcast szene aber es muss nicht nur um senden gehen sondern es kann auch einfach nur um sagen sprechen und hören im gespräch bleiben und das wird dann eben offen zugänglich abgelegt
aber nicht gesendet
es wird nicht ausgestrahlt da gibt's nicht einen sender und dann ganz viele empfänger sowie das eben klassisch beim radio der fall ist weshalb sich dann auch so sehr genaue gedanken gemacht werden.
Was man wirklich senden will kann man das sehen das muss dann durch die redaktion durch weil eben es erreicht die massen,
beim podcasten ist doch gar nicht notwendig der fall vielleicht erreicht auch niemand aber ich mach's halt trotzdem kann ich auch,
ich muss gar nicht auf so einem publikum achten ich muss gar nicht schauen ob das irgendwie ankommt ob das sich gut verkauft und die sendezeit ist nie knapp im internet ist immer platz.
Man kann auch sein eigenes publikum sein.
Auch das man kann genauso ein einziges publikum sein man kann nur für sich selbst das machen.
Was soll das diktiergerät so von früher was ja eigentlich ein konkreten sinn hat hältst du nehmen so ich will es jetzt nicht selber schreiben also sage ich's mal sagen ist ja einfacher
geht ja schneller auch und dann hält mich die technik des schreibens nicht dabei ab
den gedanken korrekt zu formulieren wenn man sich anschaut wie so ein fünfziger jahren schreibmaschinen funktioniert haben bisschen
aufwand man treiben musste um dort korrekt dinge zu notieren und zu kommunizieren war natürlich das diktiergerät insofern eine vereinfachung weil es dann eben auch wieder diesen ursprünglichen
zugang macht und ich werde auch oft gefragt sowas ich.
Was ich sozusagen für das besondere halte bei podcast uns wirklich ein weites feld aber das sprechen.
Finde ich es schon auch ein.
Ganz wichtiger faktor schlicht und ergreifend daraus dass es halt einfach auch jetzt jetzt bin ich wieder bei der evolution lange lange zeit ja auch das primäre medium war mit dem wissen kommuniziert und auch erhalten wurde.
Es war ja auch ein aufzeichnungs medium nur das halt des aufzeichnungs.
Der speicher selber war halt sehr flüchtig man konnte ja eigentlich immer nur in andere hirne hineinschreiben.
Durch das reden so und da war es dann sozusagen hattest du so eine gewisse halbwertszeit gehabt und waren,
an einem bestimmten mutationen ausgesetzt was wir heute im internet auch wiedersehen durch diese finanzierung,
aber man kann ja auch nicht sagen dass es jetzt schlecht funktioniert hätte weil der mensch hat ja dann auch tatsächlich geschafft dann eben bis zur entwicklung weiterer techniken durch solange durchzuhalten
eben dann auch andere aufzeichnungs methoden existiert bis hin zu man kann eben die sprache als solche aufnehmen was ja ein gewisser hinsicht dann auch wieder
ein.
Also kulturtechnik revolution darstellt weil vorher die schrift ja im prinzip auch nur die abwesenheit von ich kann nicht direkt das aufnehmen was sie sein dann hätte man von vornherein tonbänder gehabt
was weiß ich ob die schrift überhaupt überhaupt so populär geworden wäre.
Ja klar dann es berührt natürlich auch wieder die frage von vorhin mit der abstraktion also die schrift hat sich sagen schon unmittelbar deswegen bewährt weil man unter bedingungen von abwesenden
miteinander hat kommunizieren können man muss sie nicht ständig da sein wir können mal aufschreiben liegen lassen weggehen jemand anders liest.
Wenn er oder sie lesen konnte und konnte wieder was schreiben und so ist bei asynchrone kommunikation möglich die vorher einfach in der in der form nicht möglich war oder nicht so,
und so weiter also es gab so ganze reihe von entgrenzt phänomen von über diese vermittlungsfähig zugleich aber eben auch eine form von,
die man möglicherweise im sprechen nicht notwendig entwickelt,
nämlich die notwendigkeit sich.
Sich sehr präzise auszudrücken.
Die möglichkeit über jedes wort nachzudenken ganz konkret über jedes wort nachzudenken und in jedem einzelnen wort zu viel gewicht zu geben sowohl überlegt zu schreiben dass man.
Sich viel ballast der sprache des mündlichen,
sparen kann also man schreibt dann verdichteter also poesie ist so ein extremer fall von extrem verdichteter sprache wo jedes wort an jeder stelle wichtig ist es kommt dann auf ferse und und und und rhythmus und klang und so weiter an,
aber auch eben wissenschaftliche texte.
Zeichnet sich ja ja manchmal auch durch gelaber aus also keine frage aber,
oder floskeln und chargon aber sie zeichnet sich eben dann auch im optimalfall dadurch aus dass sie sehr präzise über dinge schreiben,
die die eben wenn sie mündlich verhandelt würden sehr viel aufwendiger sind zu produzieren oder so kann man sich vorstellen
und dann kommt dieser die frage wie du die du jetzt gerade gestellt hast hätten wir überhaupt
schrift entwickelt wenn wir schon vornherein von vornherein sprache aufzeichnen hätten können also mündlich gesprochene sprache aufzeichnen können und dann stellt sich jetzt heute die frage jetzt unter bedingungen dass wir das aufzeichnen können,
lässt sich nicht mit den mit den.
Errungenschaften der schrift also sehr präzise sein zu können sehr sparsam in der verwendung von wörtern und so weiter,
und zugleich dann noch der gewinn der der unabhängigkeit von ort und zeit in einer gewissen weise,
durch diese aufzeichnung möglichkeiten heute eine neue art von sprechen zu entwickeln eine ein ein sprechen dass diese reflexion auch von schrift aufzugreifen vermag.
Selber weiterzuentwickeln.
Also gegebenenfalls also das würde ich sagen ist nämlich meistens so ein gewisser irrtum wenn man übers mündliche sprechen spricht.
Vermeintlich immer so eine ursprünglichkeit darin entdeckt
also das ist sehr viel ursprünglicher als die schrift oder das ist sehr viel menschlicher schon als die als die schrift und so es ist weniger entfremdet oder so
es liegt uns sehr viel näher es ist sehr viel persönlicher oft heißt auch podcast in so ein persönliches medium das möchte ich nicht immer in abrede stellen aber.
Die die die entwicklung vom eines sprechens hin zu einem solchen menschlichen sprechen einem solchen.
Muss in rechnung stellen dass es all diese anderen formen der kommunikationsmöglichkeiten heute auch gibt und dann lassen sie sich ganz neue arten des sprechens auch denken ja so zumindest.
Ja die.
Ja ich denke die medien schließen sich auch nicht gegenseitig außer befruchten sich halt eher also gerade gesagt hast wissenschaftliche schreiben drückt sich halt dadurch aus dass es ja so eine extrem.
Bis hin zu so einer formalen.
Charakter hat ja dass man sozusagen dem dem text schon unmittelbar
genaue regeln wie dann etwas zu sein hat und zu funktionieren und abzulaufen hat entnehmen kann filme noch ein.
Das gipfelt ja im prinzip heutzutage in der programmierung die ja auch ein schreiben ist ja wo man eben versucht.
Brief freundschaft mit einer maschine herzustellen um ihr.
Extrem formal und extrem genau bis hin zur fehlerfrei heit zu vermitteln was sind jetzt zu tun ist das im prinzip so das maximum was ich jetzt gerade sehe aber.
Dann stellt sich eben die frage welche rolle hat jetzt das sprechen du hast ja dann ein projekt aufgenommen.
Mit dem schönen namen.
Pottler was quasi so die idee des logbuch oder des des tagebuchs aufgegriffen hat und das.
Hat es ja schon immer gegeben dass leute so verdickte tier gerät genommen haben
und da so für die nachwelt dokumentiert haben gerade im zuge dieser ganzen impeachment geschichte um donald trump wurde viel auch watergate,
beleuchtet und da gab es ja dann auch so ein mitarbeiter der ängste mitarbeiter von nixen der tatsächlich über seine
komplette zeit immer so ein audio tagebuch mitgeführt hat was dann später auch ausgewertet wurde und wunderbaren einblick in die denkweise und
die gefühlswelt gegeben hat die so schriftlich wahrscheinlich kaum reproduzierbar gewesen wäre.
Warum hast du das pott lack angefangen und was hast du dir dabei gedacht.
Gedacht ja also das war das war ende zweitausendsechzehn da lief noch dino radio-show,
so ein paar andere podcast projekte so onlineseite sozusagen und und nebenher habe ich ja an meiner
promotion gearbeitet
eine wissenschaftliche arbeit die sich mit der also in soziologisch,
wissenschaftliche arbeit die sich mit der frage nach dem begriff von medien
beschäftigt ganz konkret der frage nach wissenschaftlicher und religiöser wahrheit unter bedingungen des internets das war so die arbeit an der ich wissenschaftlich an der universität gearbeitet habe.
Also wie entsteht und konstruiert man wahrheiten unter bedingungen dieser,
vernetzten rechner beispielsweise genau die fragen die wir jetzt schon die ganze zeit.
Wenig überraschend aber die wir die ganze zeit verhandeln das ist der gegenstand diese arbeit und an dem habe ich arbeiten müssen nebenher natürlich noch lehre und so weiter was an universitäten ebenso in im rahmen so einer stelle
die produktionsstelle an der universität so anfällt und dann dachte ich mir dass,
diese podcast leidenschaft ist groß und umfangreich aber sie hält mich in einer gewissen weise ab,
vom wissenschaftlichen arbeiten das kommt mir ständig in die quere ich habe nicht zeit für beides ich muss irgendwie irgendwas muss ich da
ändern ich muss ich ich kann nicht mehr so viel podcast.
Also man muss dazu sagen pott log war ein projekt bei dem du dir vorgenommen hast über die zeitraum eines kompletten jahres an jedem einzelnen kalendertag eine sendung aufzunehmen.
Die dann wenn ich das richtig überblicke irgendwo sowas in einer länge von zehn minuten bis zu auch über eine stunde pro tag war.
Und immer nur du selber mit dir quasi so in einem selbstgespräche es war glaube ich auch der untertitel des.
Also dann.
Ja
Gab es einen offiziellen untertitel am anfang gab's nichts hier ist einfach nur podcast oder du hast ja ich weiß noch ich muss jetzt noch was verraten womit du wahrscheinlich nicht gerechnet hast so.
Ich hatte mitte dieses jahres eine längere.
Autofahrt vor mir wo ich irgendwie zwei tage unterwegs war und ich habe dann wirklich angefangen die vollständige fahrt über zwei tage lang mehr oder weniger.
Hintereinander weg mir anzuhören,
ich bin jetzt nicht bis zum dezember gekommen so.
Obwohl ich in so einem wilden modus war und mir dachte so dass,
das ist jetzt irgendwie durch und das ist irgendwie alles an habe ich natürlich nicht geschafft aber ich
ich bin glaube ich so zumindest durch die ersten drei monate durchgegangen die mich natürlich
besonders interessiert haben weil so ein bisschen verstehen wollte.
Durch welche untiefen du sozusagen dort erstmal marschiert bist weil wir ja wieder jetzt eben schon angedeutet hast im prinzip die ausrichtung dieses podcast dann auch während du es gemacht hast geändert hast.
Wie war das so für dich wie womit hast du angefangen und was was kam dir so in den sinn.
Ja also wie gesagt der der ursprung war eben ich,
nicht mehr so viel podcasten jetzt jeden tag.
Ja gut aber da hast du es ja schon gemacht.
Ja genau aber nein nein nein das war tatsächlich der die vor überlegung war dass ich jetzt nicht mehr so viel podcasten kann weil es mir in meiner arbeit ja genau
das war die überlegung und und und dann war die konsequenz entweder nicht mehr so wie podcast oder halt jeden tag dafür aber,
das für meine arbeit nutzen und das war die ausrichtung also ich wollte es ich
konnte nicht aufhören mit dem podcasten da ich war irgendwie hockt und da wollte ich da wollte ich dran dran bleiben ich wollte auch,
hatte auch das den eindruck da kann man noch sehr viel mehr experimentieren da kann man noch sehr viel mehr machen mit ich habe noch
gar nicht dass alles hören wollen können was ich hören wollte also vielleicht gibt es noch nicht vielleicht muss ich das selber machen ich möchte damit irgendwie weiter arbeiten.
Und es wäre doch gelacht wenn ich das nicht wissenschaftlich nutzen könnte also muss ich das irgendwie
für meine wissenschaftliche arbeit nutzen können und so entstand dann die idee eines denk tagebuchs was wirklich sich sehr konkret mit meiner arbeit beschäftigt also mit dem mit der mit dem schreiben einer dissertation mit dem lernen an universitäten mit dem besuch von konferenzen und den ganzen prozessen die das in irgendeiner form vermitteln jeden tag.
Diese tagesform bot sich an weil sie eine gewisse verpflichtung bereithält also das war so lang der vorsatz fürs neue jahr
ende zweitausendsechzehn nahm ich mir vor das mache ich jetzt jeden tag und
wenn man sich das vornimmt dann muss man das eben durchziehen und da gibt's halt auch keine männer und arme und in dem fall gab's wirklich kein wenn und aber also wenn man dann so ein bisschen reingerutscht ist dann denkt man sich so jetzt gebe ich auch nicht auf das denkt man sich zwar schon mitte januar.
Und dann kommen halt noch so ein paar monate aber ja man kann das halt trotzdem durchziehen und heißt dass es an manchen tagen eben nur fünf minuten sind wo ich sage ich habe heute wirklich keine zeit,
nichts zu sagen und dann an anderen tagen eben eineinhalb stunden oder so und im schnitt sind jetzt glaube ich sowas wie vierundzwanzig minuten pro tag.
Wenn man es jetzt oder hundertvierundvierzig stunden genau und.
Das hinterher das nur fun fact also ich habe das transkribieren lassen von google sind so dreitausendsechshundert zeiten.
Also kann man.
Eine menge mitmachen also es ist eine menge an material und aber wichtig war mir tatsächlich dass das für meine arbeit genutzt ist also dass ich das dass ich das als werkzeug sofort verwenden kann
und dann muss man sehen was dabei passiert ja also ich wusste nur die themen die kommen durch meine arbeit ja da muss ich nicht suchen
ich habe jeden tag muss ich arbeiten und jeden tag kann ich darüber sprechen
ich lese texte ich spreche darüber ich schreibe darüber und darüber kann ich nochmal nachdenken für für mich mit mir selber zu beginn dachte ich auch.
Die formatvielfalt noch sehr viel bunter vielleicht kann ich auch mal schnipsel bauen vielleicht kann ich mal mit jemandem ein interview aufnehmen ich war da gar nicht festgelegt aber innerhalb von den ersten wochen tatsächlich
begann das für mich schon so ein ganz interessante eigendynamik zu entwickeln
dass man plötzlich feststellt man ist mit sich in einem gesprächs zusammenhang aus dem man so leicht nicht mehr rauskommt und auch gar nicht will weil das fasziniert
also man spricht mit sich jeden tag
und man verspricht so wie wir jetzt sprechen miteinander aber mit sich selbst nämlich vermittelt über ein mikrofon und und kopfhörer
man hört seine eigene stimme man spricht mit sich auf eine art und weise wie man normalerweise nur mit anderen spricht,
nur noch sehr viel besser man hört sich sehr viel klarer man spricht sehr viel ruhiger man hat sehr viel mehr zeit.
Und so weiter und so fort also man spricht in einer art und weise mit sich die einen selber irritiert als als gesprächs zusammenhang so eine gewisse eigene logik entwickelt und das ist unendlich faszinierend gewesen also gleich am anfang.
Es gibt ja viele leute auch wenn ich.
Ich denke dass immer nur so ein vorübergehendes phänomen aber das wirst du auch schon gehört haben sollten wenn man die versucht so ein bisschen podcasting heranzubringen oder nur an den gedanken zu gewöhnen sie könnten mal in einem podcast mitmachen.
Dann kommen so sätze wie ich habe probleme meine eigene stimme zu hören.
Und ich hab mich mal gefragt warum denn das eigentlich so ist weil es mir persönlich eigentlich so noch nie ging vielleicht hat das damit zu tun dass ich so ein egozentrische typ bin aber.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen angst sich selbst an sich ranzulassen sondern eine eine fell vergegenwärtigen des.
Das selbst die durch die stimme irgendwie nochmal sehr viel intensiver ist als wenn man was was ich sein eigenes geschriebenes lesen würde oder so.
Ja ich würde sagen das sind also mindestens zwei phänomene die da interessant sind das eine ist natürlich dass man mit sich selbst in einen kontakt tritt der einem möglichst,
möglicherweise sehr viel näher ist als einem lieb ist man möchte mit sich gar nicht so viel zu tun haben dass man möglicherweise aber auch
ist es natürlich diese dieser fremdheit effekt
die eigene stimme so zu hören wie man sie nun sonst nicht hört über kopfhörer hört man sie ja eben nicht über die knochen und den schädel vermittelt und deswegen sehr viel basslastige und so weiter also das kennt man ja alles mittlerweile aber also man hört sich,
in einer art und weise die sehr viel ähnlicher dem es wie andere menschen einhören müssen weiß man auch nicht genau weil jedes hoher ist anders und und so weiter.
Dass man davon einmal abgesehen hört man sich aber in einer gewissen form verfremdet man hört sich als wäre man nicht man selbst
man hört sich eben nicht wie man sich beim sprechen hört sondern man hat sich anders man gerät so eine minimale distanz die man gar nicht so richtig in worte fassen kann die man aber sehr gut hört
plötzlich zwischen sich und sich und dann wird man sich selbst zu sagen,
technisch vermittelt in diesem sinnlichen
erfahrungsgemäß zusammenhang wird man sich plötzlich fremd und dieses fremdheit moment damit glaube ich haben sehr viele probleme,
ganz einfach gesagt drückt das sich dann immer da durchaus ich,
ich mag meine stimme nicht wie die klingt ich höre die nicht gern oder was du halt auch gerade gesagt hast,
aber ich glaube was dahinter so ein bisschen lauert ist auch diese diese plötzliche unruhe die entsteht wenn man sich selbst in dieser form fremd ist,
wenn man sich so fremd wahrnimmt und diese wahrnehmung dimension ist aber wirklich sehr wichtig für die frage nach der.
Nach der gesprächspartner oder nach der dynamik überhaupt in einem solchen gespräch.
Auch weil man sich ja auch dann so hört wie andere einhören hier moment der wahrheit in gewisser hinsicht auch.
Genau und ja also in in meiner beschäftigung mit dem mit diesem täglichen selbstgesprächen dann entstehen natürlich ganz viele fragen die sich daran anschließen etwa,
etwas fragen nach nach dem nach der form eines gesprächs
nach der nach der geschichte von gespräch zusammenhängen über viele tage hinweg wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben also es lässt sich zwar aufzeichnen jetzt.
Aber das heißt doch nicht dass ich das alles noch mal alles mir hundertmal anhöre sondern was ich vor tagen gesprochen habe,
das mag noch mehr in erinnerung sein oder auch nicht
halt schon längst wieder irgendwie rausgefallen durch anderes ersetzt durch andere aktualitätsgrad irgendwelche anderen relevanten und so verdrängt worden sein aber wie
wie schaffe ich da so einen zusammenhang herzustellen und wie wie wie erzeuge ich den im gespräch wie greife ich immer wieder fäden auf und so weiter also das zu entwickeln als format als gesprächs zusammenhang
und als format das war so
dass man dann so die fragen die dabei entstanden sind in der reflexion dieser methode dessen was mache ich da eigentlich ja also in diesem darüber nachdenken was mache ich da eigentlich
und das fällt mir jetzt deswegen ein weil,
weil das so als als reflexionsfrage bewegung dieses tuns
als dieses werkzeug ja so wie jeder bastler und jede bastler drin das auch sieht man baut sich irgendetwas und man denkt darüber nach wie baue ich das warum baue ich das wozu eigentlich manchmal weiß man's gar nicht vorher so genau.
Man baut das trotzdem.
Und dann entsteht dabei etwas daraus genau und eine solche logik entsteht eben auch ganz besonders in diesem format des sprechens in dem format nicht nur des sprechens sondern auch das gespräch
und man hört sich wie wie man einen anderen hört und das führt dann zu sofern momenten wie dass man sich auch irritiert.
An der eigenen stimme man stolpert über worte die man jetzt das erste mal,
hört man hört sich immer auch wenn man also sagen ohne kopfhörer vermittelt mit sich selbst sprechen würde aber man hört sich nochmal ganz anders so ein bisschen verfremdet eben und dann stolpert man über begriffe die man gewohnt ist zu verwenden,
und plötzlich gerät man ins zweifeln und man stockt und man zögert
man stottert oder stammbild und so weiter und all das verändert tatsächlich dann diese form des nachdenkens und und und schaltet sozusagen so verschiedene reflexion momente ein die wissenschaftlich jetzt
wieder bedacht wünschenswerte effekte sind man denkt darüber anders nach und und
über solche phänomene im sprechen selber mit nachzudenken die mitzuführen,
in der täglichen arbeit in dieser auseinandersetzung mit dem medium mit dem podcasten mit dem sprechen aber eben mit den ganz konkreten an den ganz konkreten fragen
meiner wissenschaftlichen arbeit und so das war's.
Dass mir beim zuhören auch aufgefallen und und und ich muss sagen auch dass das zuhören bei einem,
offensichtlich ein selbstgespräche hat nochmal so eine ganz andere dimension aufgemacht weil
weil man ja sozusagen also podcast ja nun schon gedacht hast und wie ich auch schon eine trommel die seit seit jahren auch trommler so dieser persönliche oder persönlichste form der kommunikation
die podcast meiner meinung nach halt nach wie vor sind das hat er dann im prinzip auf die spitze getrieben dadurch weil persönlicher als mit sich selber zu reden geht's ja dann irgendwie auch fast gar nicht mehr.
Und jetzt hast du das wort reflexion benutzt.
Mir würde auch noch rückkopplung einfallen so im positiven sinne ja also man hört sich selber.
Zu also man hört sich dir sonst immer aber man hört sich halt nicht immer zu.
Und und die form gewählt hast war sozusagen ein ein aktives selbst zuhören man das dass man jedes wort oder jeden satz eine formulierung während man sie spricht im prinzip auch zwangshaft.
Zwangsweise zuhört.
Wahrnimmt nochmal auseinander konstruiert also das was das hirn,
mal so aus dem affekt heraus zusammengebaut hat
wird sofort wieder dis assembliert wird auseinander genommen.
Man versucht sich selbst zu verstehen stellt fest.
Das macht überhaupt gar keinen sinn was ja jetzt gerade sagt er oder das trifft es nicht so genau das war eigentlich gar nicht das was ich sagen wollte was ja auch nochmal schön klar macht dass.
Auch das reden jetzt auch nur der versuch ist erst mal was ganz anderes abzubilden was irgendwie noch tiefer in einem drin ist also der gedanke.
Ist da aber man muss ihn erstmal zu fassen kriegen so versucht den gedanken wirklich zu fassen.
Durch sprache spricht es aus ließ diese sprache wieder ein.
Dadurch vergleicht es sich mit dem was man im kopf hat man stellt fest.
Da ist jetzt eine gewisse dissonanz auch schönes wort in dem zusammenhang auch der ton ja mit drin steckt.
Das kriegt man mit und man korrigiert sich um ein verfeinert sich.
Das war die eine ebene und die unmittelbare ebene die andere ebene die bei dir da der reflexion noch mit drin war war dass du dann.
Angefangen hat das war am an also wie gesagt ich habe nur die ersten drei monate gehört ich habe dann streckenweise hier und da auch später nochmal reingehört.
Dass du am anfang die ganze zeit über ja auch kommentare bekommen hast weil leute zugehört haben was kennst du überhaupt jemand der das ganze gehört hat gab es menschen die wirklich alles gehört haben.
Ja es gibt so ein paar ja genau.
So und die haben dann vermutlich auch viel kommentiert und das war am anfang auch versucht diese kommentare
und die kritik an dem was du gesagt hast was du dir eigentlich nur zu dir gesagt hast ja aber was natürlich für alle dann quasi so eine aussage war auch noch wieder mit einzubauen wie du dann damit gehadert hast und dass du dieses kann ja so nicht sehen und es.
Geht es mir auch irgendwie gar nicht geht ja sowieso was ganz anderes also man musste die ganze zeit über verschiedene ebenen und metaebene hin und her hangeln.
Allein um dem gespräch und dem gedanken dann noch folgen zu fand ich irgendwie.
Faszinierend.
Ja also die die frage wie das wie das ganz praktisch geht das ist,
war für mich auch die faszinierende frage weil eben ich habe mir die,
also experimentell sondern wenn man das als ich hab das hinterher dann experimental system genannt.
Wenn man das also als experimental system als experimentelle anordnung in so einem ganz streng wissenschaftlichen sinne begreift dieses dieses selbstgespräche format dieses projekt im ganzen
dann kann man das ja nochmal auf verschiedenen ebenen beschreiben also meine meine routine zu sagen meine tägliche
routine der des des selbstgespräche die begann ja tatsächlich also ohne vorbereitung ja ich habe mich einfach hingesetzt rechner war an
er ist immer an und dann und dann aufgenommen und im im nächsten moment.
Mich selbst dabei überrascht jetzt über etwas sprechen zu müssen
ich wusste natürlich woran ich den ganzen tag schon rum denke und was was mich beschäftigt und so weiter also wie du sagst es sind so gedanken mit denen man sich herumschlägt aber
im im sprechen selber entwickelt sich eine gewisse notwendigkeit etwas auszudrücken die vorher in der form vielleicht gar nicht bestanden hatte und da würde ich auch.
Ein haken und so ein bisschen widersprechen nicht alles ist notwendig als gedanke schon vor formuliert irgendwo tief drin und noch viel weniger im gehirn aber.
Ich habe nicht gesagt dass es vor formuliert ich habe nur gesagt er ist da.
Genau aber solange die vorstellung dass etwas sehr viel tiefer und da ist also da ist irgendwas da sein.
Es wird vielleicht auch erst in dem moment wo man versucht drüber zu sprechen so aber es,
es ist schon irgendein ist es ist es so ein so ein bisschen so schrödingers katze mäßig ja also es ist es lebt,
noch nicht es ist aber auch nicht tot
und es wird irgendwie erst in dem moment wo ich versuche es zu beschreiben wo ich versuche den ganzen natur zu geben,
dessen fassbar zu werden in dem moment entscheidet sich sozusagen was es wirklich ist.
Und man kann das hören ja also genau was da auch immer vorher da war.
In dem moment indem ich darüber spreche wird es ein gesprochener gedanke oder entstehen diese gespräche gesprochenen gedanken
und und sie entstehen im sprechen selber diese diese erkenntnis formuliert sich im sprechen selber aber sie
man muss das eben durchführen also man kann das nicht man kann es nicht hinterher nur zusammenfassen sozusagen jetzt gebe ich noch kurz zu protokoll was ich die ganze zeit gedacht habe sondern es entwickelt sich eben im gespräch also in diesem ringen um das.
Darstellen in sprache und zwar gesprochene sprache
das heißt also in der sprache die ein klang hat die irritiert weil sie so klingt und nicht anders und weil sie deutsch ist und nicht englisch oder
ich habe auch an einigen stellen über englische sprache nachgedacht beispielsweise es gab so ein paar momente in denen,
englische sprache ein auch irritiert hat ich war zu der zeit auch einmal zwei wochen in new york und ab da so ein paar sachen.
Das heißt auf der straße aufgegriffen oder sonst wie gehört und es gibt so ein paar momente formulierungen die einen plötzlich irritieren und so weiter aber wie man dann ganz praktisch den zusammenhang,
hält in einem solchen gespräch über ein ganzes jahr lang wie sich themen entwickeln aber wie man daran
auch diese methode selber entwickelt ohne ständig immer wieder von neuem mann zu fangen
das ist das entscheidende und die routine und das war das was ich gerade noch hab einführen wollen die routine ist was mir so ein bisschen diese struktur gegeben hat an diesen fragen arbeiten zu können.
Ich habe mich hingesetzt ohne vorbereitung angefangen zu sprechen ich habe das aufgenommen
und hinterher nur ganz ganz sporadisch nach sagen störgeräusche wenn irgendwas gekippt hat oder so nachbearbeitet und die rausgeschnitten,
wenn ich gewusst habe oder sowas das rausgeschnitten sonst das ganze bearbeitet gelassen aber beim durchhören nochmal sagen mich gehört daraufhin.
Nach der postproduktion
eine kleine beschreibung geschrieben für die website damit ich so eine folgenbeschreibung hab die nochmal so eine ganz eigene art von zugang darstellt zu so einem gespräch dass man gerade eben hatte das ist wie wenn man eben ein gespräch mit irgendjemandem hätte und
immer kurz hinterher ein kleiner wie so ein kleines.
Episoden cover beschreiben müsste und schreiben sie
worum ging es eigentlich gerade und dann findet man formulierungen die man möglicherweise gerade entdeckt hatte
greift die auf und schreibt darüber und dieses jahr kleine text hat so eine so ein eigenen charme auch der hat so eine ganz eigene form die ist irgendwie geschlossener und zugleich steht sie für etwas was er überhaupt nicht ausdrücken vermag und so
es sind doch noch eine andere zugang zu diesem gespräch gerade und dann habe ich noch immer ein ein bild ausgewählt was ich an dem tag fotografiert hatte oder also mit meinem smartphone oder einen screenshot oder sonstwas als episoden cover
das dann hochgeladen und in diesen schlaufen er also in diesen in diesen bewegung von dem von der aufnahme.
Postproduktion beschreibung bild hochladen fertig abgelegt.
Nimmt dieses gespräch nochmal so wendungen auf,
die die das ja die so eine eigene routinen noch darstellen die dann sich in dieses gespräch mit einklinkt.
Das heißt du hast jede folge nicht nur eingesprochen sondern auch nochmal abgehört komplett vollständig.
Also ich habe so störgeräusche kann man ja dann an der spur sehen wo es wo es clip.
Du hast nicht konsequent nochmal alles gehört.
Aber schon fast also ja schon fast durchgehört
also manches habe ich auch mit kapiteln versehen beispielsweise manche folgen,
immer wenn ich zum beispiel texte gelesen habe an manchen tagen ist mir nicht wahnsinnig viel eingefallen oder aber mir ist ein text in meiner wissenschaftlichen arbeit irgendwo begegnet wie das einem ja manchmal passiert wenn man so kulturwissenschaftler ist
beginnt am texte und findet man interessant und dann habe ich die vorgelesen also dann hab ich habe
oft texte vorgelesen und dann darüber gleich im anschluss über diesen ausschnitt mit mir ins gespräch gekommen
ja ich hab den text eingelesen und bin dann ins gespräch gekommen über diesen text und habe darüber nachgedacht und das nochmal eine ganz andere form auch des lesens wenn man also direkt.
Zu einem direkt im anschluss mit sich selbst darüber nochmal ins gespräch gerät und das mit kapitel marken zu versehen dazu ist es halt wichtig dass du,
dass du jetzt nochmal anhörst.
Was wir in allen folgen alleine komplett.
Es ist nicht irgendwie noch variiert mit irgendwelchen gästen oder sowas.
Nee ich habe nie variiert das war tatsächlich ich war ich war nicht immer alleine ich habe oft auch zum beispiel
unter menschen mein selbstgespräche geführt aber dann zumindest geschützt
durch kopfhörer und mikrofon also auf konferenzen im zug toiletten und so weiter also unmöglichsten situationen aber es musste ja passieren irgendwann an diesem tag musste das passieren und das ging halt an manchmal nicht anders.
Und ich habe es nicht immer vor zwölf uhr nachts hochladen können es gab manchmal technische probleme dann
habe ich es zwölf uhr nachts war so ohnehin nicht die deadline sondern die deadline bevor ich ins bett gehe.
Also wenn ich um ein uhr ins bett gegangen bin dann ist der tag endete halt um ein uhr dann am nächsten tag aber das egal der der tageszusammenfassung ist dadurch gewährleistet weil der tag ist eben die zeit in der ich wach bin zumindest mein verständnis dafür mein arbeitssuche.
Was hat dich denn am meisten überrascht jetzt.
Während du das gemacht hast und während du so über die zeit dein format gefunden hast dein modus gefunden hast und vielleicht auch herausgefunden hast was nicht machen willst.
Was gut funktioniert was was waren denn so deine.
Erkenntnisse entdeckung du gemacht hast.
Man könnte ja sagen okay wisst ihr dann selber zu hören bis darüber nachdenken das kann man,
war vorher irgendwie klar irgendwie aber wenn man's dann tut ist es ja dann doch meistens noch mal was anderes und manches wirkt vielleicht stärker und hat andere auswirkungen als das was man so erwartet hat.
Also es gibt natürlich sehr sehr viele entdeckungen die ich
in diesem sprechen mir über meinen tage erarbeitet habe also über die dinge an denen ich an den fragen an denen ich gearbeitet habe dinge die ich zum beispiel über den medienbegriff gelernt hatte über die ich,
in diesem sprechen hab nachdenken können also dinge die dann eingeflossen sind in texte die ich geschrieben habe in vorträge die ich gehalten,
und so weiter also so ganz konkrete erzeugnisse des wissenschaftlichen arbeitens wie sie ebenso anfallen wenn man an fragen arbeitet etwa zu metaphern theoretischen überlegungen im anschuss anhand blumenberg
medien begriffliche fragen und so weiter an denen ich gearbeitet habe so das sind so eigentlich ernstzunehmender wissenschaftlichen gegenstände,
zugleich aber habe ich,
endlich viel über diese arbeitsform selber gelernt also über dieses experimentelle setting indem diese arbeit dann sich hat vollziehen können.
Das ist,
das setting des gesprächs also das sprechens mit sich selbst dieses selbst gespräch und zwar nicht als selbstgespräche im sinne von ich weiß sonst nichts zu tun oder so als zeitvertreib oder es ist eine gängige menschliche praxis.
Man spricht miteinander und auch eben mit sich selbst sondern als strenges wissenschaftliches instrument für erkenntnis für
für wissenschaftlich strenge erkenntnis also gerade dieses strenge was vermeintlich sonst immer dem text ganz spezifisch zukommt als kriterium
nur der text ist streng deswegen wir sprechen auf konferenzen miteinander weil das zählt jetzt nicht so viel wie den aufsatz worüber man so gebrütet hat indem man umformuliert hat und geschraubt und so weiter
zugleich aber diese stränge auch im sprechen selber zu entwickeln weil eben das sprechen beispielsweise anders als das schreiben ein ständig mit dem.
Mit dem gesprochenen,
wieder konfrontiert und man stolpert man irritiert sich man entwickelt mein ring um diese worte und dieses ringen diese auseinandersetzung.
Das ist etwas was zu vielem experimenteller.
Wissenschaftlichen arbeiten dann in den texten in den sogenannten produkten erzeugnissen wissenschaftliche arbeit vollkommen fehlt
und dann heißt es aber zugleich wissenschaftliche erkenntnis muss transparent sein also wie komme ich zu den dass es die aufgabe schlechthin von wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftlern dass sie transparent darstellen können wie sie zu diesen erkenntnissen gelangt sind,
und das fehlt aber vielen texten völlig,
da steht nicht drin ich habe mit meiner kollegin gesprochen und,
beim mittagessen kamen wir auf die idee das ist ja großartig und jetzt schreibe ich das auf das steht da nicht drin sondern da steht folgende erkenntnis,
doppelpunkt und dann oder lehrer tour hinweis xy dass die kollegin einem gesagt hat schau mal in dem buch nach.
Geht natürlich auch davon aus es tut nichts zur sache.
Ja ja ist nicht relevant.
Ist nicht relevant aber das halt quatsch das ist quatsch und das lässt sich zeigen.
Das quatsch ist weil weil wie diese erkenntnis zustande kommt.
Nicht beliebig für die erkenntnis selber die form der erkenntnis selber ist in dieser durchführung selbst vermittelt und diese transparenz ist nicht einfach nur nette idee die wir wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler von uns selber fordern.
Sondern die ist bedingungen dafür dass wir das als verlässliche wissenschaftliche erkenntnis begreifen können,
diese transparenz wie man dahin gekommen ist und ich würde sagen also so von von so 'ner ganz einfachen transparenz forderung aus lässt sich schon.
Lässt sich schon diese notwendigkeit zeigen warum man warum man da möglicherweise den den prozess hin zu dieser erkenntnis selber transparenter gestalten kann wie das eben sich in einem solchen gespräch anbietet.
Es spricht natürlich auch viel dafür hinterher einfach nur die abkürzung zu zeigen hier das ist der kürzeste mögliche weg
ihr müsst ja jetzt nicht hundertvierundvierzig stundenlang mir zuhören wie ich zu dieser erkenntnis kam sondern also
folgende stationen sind die notwendigen und die könnte abgehen dann kommt ihr auch zu dieser erkenntnis und dank dieser verlässlichkeit oder diese dankbarkeit des wegs oder oder die reproduzierbarkeit wissenschaftlicher erkenntnis und so weiter und so fort all diese kriterien
sind ja dadurch auch gewährleistet.
Isak newton hat das aber gemacht so also der hat ja umfangreich beschrieben wie er da im apfel garten saß und das fallen des apfels hat ihn erkenntnisse zur gravitation gebracht.
Ich bin mir sicher der hat einen podcast gemacht hätte das.
Nee also genau und und die frage ist eben wie wie man so mit den mit den mitteln.
Seiner zeit auch den technologischen mitteln umgeht und solche formen findet und zugleich eben ist es aber auch eine riesenmaschine gewesen für mich,
produktiv zu bleiben,
in der zeit ist viel passiert auch in meinem leben ja ich habe eine stelle in witten verloren ich bin in die schweiz ausgewandert ich habe eine neue stelle dort angefangen ich war dazwischen monat arbeitslos ich war auf fast zwanzig konferenzen und workshops in dem jahr und habe
wirklich viele vorträge halten viel mehr als ich mir hätte jemals zumuten wollen aber
passiert bei all diesen dingen damit das nicht vollkommen auseinanderfällt war das wie so eine maschine die das alles zusammengehalten hat der gespräch zusammenhang,
jeden tag mit mir selber nochmal darüber sprechen zu können hat es mir ermöglicht,
auch in den unmöglichsten unter den unmöglichsten umständen noch produktiv zu bleiben noch an den eigenen fragen dran zu bleiben weil man weiß
da gibt's dieses gespräch das läuft so mit und und und man verhandelt diese erkenntnis zu der man kommt,
transparent offen legt das offen ab und um.
Und gestaltet diesen prozess selber die erkenntnis selber ist dann diese durchführung dieses experiments das ist nicht nur einfach das fazit
die erkenntnis ist nicht nur das fazit ist nicht nur einfach die zusammenfassung am ende dieser hundertvierundvierzig stunden am ende des jahres so jetzt nochmal das factsheet sozusagen das sind die facts die habe ich herausgefunden sondern der weg
ist sozusagen die erkenntnis es ist diese diese erkenntnis ist quasi ihre ihre.
Der der prozess der herstellung dieser dieser erkenntnis und wer das wär das unter schlägt.
Ist meines erachtens wissenschaftlich fahrlässig ja also es gibt disziplin gerade zum beispiel technologische also ingenieurs und technische
disziplinen die die sprechen über andere dinge die sprechen aber dann nicht unbedingt
immer um erkenntnis da geht es dann darum zum beispiel dass die maschine funktioniert
da muss ich nicht wissen wie ich dazu kam herauszufinden wie das funktioniert da reicht zu beschreiben wie das funktioniert
und dann kann ich das reproduzieren dann kann ich es bauen aber die frage ist ob das dann erkenntnis ist oder ob man funktionierende maschinen baut also ob's
ob sie sozusagen die frage nach der der wahrheit
also der der der wahrheit als als eine einer qualität von setzen über die welt ob wir dann über wahrheit sprechen oder ob ihr über das funktionieren sprechen funktioniert funktioniert nicht maschine geht maschine ist kaputt
ob das identisch ist mit einem wahrheitsbewegung dass es dann eine frage die die philosophie.
Aber wenn man wenn man jetzt zur erkenntnissen kommt und.
Und diese gut darlegen kann dann muss man ja dann in diesem prozess auch.
Kürzer zusammenzufassen den weg auch finden können um zu sagen hier.
Meiner auffassung nach ist das so unser strukturiert ist vielleicht ein sophie musischen fragen
nochmal anders sein als wenn man das jetzt mit naturwissenschaft vergleichen weil da hat man wie so eine messung und zahlen rein daran kann man das irgendwie belegen ist ja mal die eine rente logik dann irgendwie relativ klar
also philosophischen kulturwissenschaftler menschlichen gedanken auseinander setzung
wo man sich irgendwie so ein symbol raum auch erstmal zurechtlegen muss um darüber dann überhaupt irgendwelche aussagen treffen zu können.
Sehe ich schon dass dass dieser prozess dann teil des muss aber.
Heißt es dass der schriftlichen arbeiten so nicht auch vorhanden ist also man kann auch nur sagen das jetzt hier so meine erkenntnis und fertig und da wird ja eine gewisse herleitung auch enthalten sein inwiefern.
Ist jetzt in deinem gesprochenen weg mehr informationen drin.
Hallo
also das betrifft das berührt jetzt gleich unterschiedliche ich hoffe ich krieg,
ich behalte das jetzt sozusagen in unserem gespräch wach das eine ist
die unterscheidung zwischen naturwissenschaftlichen disziplin wo das möglicherweise anders ist.
Und den geistes oder kulturwissenschaftler disziplinen wo das der fall sein könnte,
also eben dass die herleitung wichtiger ist für das ergebnis selbst als eben in anderen fällen
das wage ich mal zu bezweifeln und unter anderem auch mit naturwissenschaftlern ich habe vorhin den begriff des experimental systems gebracht dass ein begriff der den denn hat hans-jörg rheinberger entwickelt er ist wissenschaft historiker aber auch
molekularbiologin promovierte harmonisierter molekularbiologie soweit ich weiß und probiert da ambitionierter
historiker wissenschaft historiker und der schreibt über experimental systeme unter anderem in der biologie.
Und er sagt eben genau die reflexion die selbst
das selbstverständnis von wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler in der naturwissenschaftlichen disziplin ist genau das man man forscht man baut irgendeine maschine ein experiment man steht in seinem labor und so weiter und am schluss kommt zack fertig das ergebnis und das schreibt man dann auf unser labor bericht
praktisch der bericht am schluss das vor allem das ergebnis das ist worum es geht das ist die wissenschaft die erkenntnis und retrospektive ist das dann immer so zu beschreiben
ich habe das gemacht damit ich rausfinde das und das
das ist aber nicht was passiert in diesem labors sondern da werden dinge gemacht von dem er überhaupt nicht weiß warum man die macht den ganzen tag macht man dinge von denen man keine ahnung hat warum man sie macht und wie man sie macht und so weiter und man reflektiert das auch nicht weiter und am schluss passiert irgendwas ist,
es knallt es zischt es stinkt und es war erkenntnis sozusagen.
Eureka und dann hat man diesen moment.
Zack und hinterher wird dann irgendwas gebastelt in diesem bericht was dann irgendwie sowas wie ein fazit darstellt das muss nicht immer der fall sein und manchmal kann man das auch rekonstruieren die schritte die man so aber man kann nicht wirklich behaupten
das experiment
ist von vornherein geplant und durchgeführt worden zur austreten zum zum tüv a reaktion dass man irgendwie auf diese antworten kommt die man als antworten haben wollte also man hat nicht immer am anfang die frage
um dies dann geht sondern oft ist die frage selbst abwesend und das ist was rein berger das systemische ding nennt,
und die ganze apparaturen die wir bauen das systemische ding.
Also das wissenschafts ding die noch unbekannte frage dass der gegenstand worum es geht von dem man aber noch nicht weiß dass es darum geht und wir bauen uns komplexe maschinen und apparaturen nur um uns auch diesen fragen,
zuwenden zu können um diese fragen zu bekommen nicht nur um antworten zu bekommen es gibt natürlich auch hypothesen testen die experimente aber es gibt auch eben experimente bei denen es selbst die frage noch nicht klar und das macht es umso spannender darüber nachzudenken
das lässt sich daran zeigen an diesen wissenschaftssystem untersuchung dass eben die naturwissenschaften oft auch genauso wenig
wissen worum es ihnen eigentlich geht was was sie da tun und dass die durchführung.
Also die herleitung des wissens sehr viel mehr an der an dem wissen selber an der erkenntnis selber beteiligt ist.
Als man das gemeinhin annimmt wenn man davon ausgeht dass das erkennt dass die erkenntnis ist eben,
am schluss da herauskommt das ist das eine und das andere ist dass die.
Dass die herleitung im im kulturwissenschaftler kontext im sprechen.
Möglicherweise nochmal transparenter gemacht werden kann als im schreiben,
weil sie weil sie einen eigenen modus der vermittlung darstellt
im schreiben kann man das auch man kann das auch aufschreiben es gibt auch texte die sich so lesen lassen also wenn man beispielsweise an grafische untersuchungen denkt
studien von sozial- und kultur die da so rausgehen in die welt und feldforschung treiben beispielsweise bei irgendwelchen.
Bei irgendwelchen zu irgendwelchen früher fremden völkern ja also die die volks.
Gehen ja.
Die erfahren dann zu den fremden und untersuchen die und leben damit und so weiter und die führen dann beispielsweise auch tagebuch
also fällt tagebuch so in dieser form und die fotografien sind dann text geworden auseinandersetzungen genau mit dieser erzeugten erzeugung von von von wissenschaftliche erkenntnis.
Ich würde nicht in abrede stellen dass das schriftlich gar nicht geht es ist nur nicht beliebig ob man das schriftlich macht oder mündlich,
wieder diese diese vorstellung dass das beliebig ist welches medium ich wähle
um zu meiner erkenntnis zu kommen geht davon aus dass es erkenntnis als irgendwas vollkommen abstraktes gibt abstrakt unabhängig von mir der diese erkenntnis begreift oder anderen die das nachvollziehen müssen oder der welt
selbst der welt mit all ihren gegenständen und der zeit,
historisch gewordene gegenstände und so weiter dagegen muss man meines erachtens philosophisch immer wieder darauf hinweisen und das zeigen
das erkenntnis immer
in ihrer gesellschaft in ihrer zeit die erkenntnis von konkreten subjekten zu konkreten gegenständen ist also das ist immer diese vermittlungsfähig aktion zwischen gegenstand und beobachterin
hat und diese vermittlung von selber bedient sich dann eben medien der vermittlung sprache schrift und so weiter und die selber.
Gestalten aber diese vermittlung mit erkenntnis ist nichts anderes als dieses gesamte vermittlungsgutschein dann
und zwar im hinblick auf bestimmte wissenschaftliche verfahren verlässlichkeiten und so weiter aber das mitzudenken
und mit transparent zu gestalten darum muss es wissenschaft gehen und auch naturwissenschaften das
machen viele naturwissenschaftler naturwissenschaftler auch auch die vorstellung dass das so ganz unabhängig von den,
stattfindet was da so ferne planeten und so weiter betrifft oder so ist es nicht mal in der physik,
so klar der der beobachter oder die beobachterin die taucht da plötzlich auch auf in ganz anderen formen
also dass das irgendwie so eine ungenauigkeit beispielsweise unschärfe oder das ist das ist
von irgendwelchen messverfahren abhängt und dass die eben nicht beliebig sind zu welchen ergebnissen ich komme also ich phänomen erkennt man auch in der naturwissenschaften in.
Allen wissenschaften die sich ganz konkret in ihren gegenständen schon mit sprachlichen sinnhaften formen beschäftigen ist das natürlich nochmal sehr viel
sehr viel prominenter
ist das sehr viel prominenter weil der gegenstand selber ist eindeutig sinnhaft sprachlich und so weiter symbolisch formatiert
und das macht es zugleich aber spannend also das macht auch diese diese.
Transparenz nochmal sehr viel meines erachtens sehr viel notwendiger.
Jetzt bist du ja.
Selber dann irgendwann auf die idee gekommen dass dein pott log.
Ein tagebuch deine,
auseinandersetzung mit dir selbst und mit deinen mit den fragen die du dir dann täglich und auch langfristig ja gestellt hast.
Mehr sein kann als nur.
Ein eigenes diskurs system in dem man die sinne schärft und dann vielleicht zu antworten kommt die man beim normalen unausgesprochenen denken so nicht kommen würde.
Und dann ist letzten endes der podcast zu deiner dissertation geworden.
Ja ja genau also ich hatte das nicht auf dem schirm ich hatte das ja nie als ein solches als eine dissertation oder so intendiert.
Aber die stand auf dem programm sozusagen.
Genau aber die destillation war die arbeit die ich an der ich schrieb sondern dass diese andere arbeit.
Man ja genau.
Und die situation schreibt man klar steht sogar in den provisionsabrechnung in dieser welt drin dass die geschriebene texte sind die müssen gebunden abgegeben werden in so und so viel exemplaren
das steht da alles sehr genau drin auch das ist im übrigen natürlich aufgeschrieben also das erzählt dir niemand es erzählt ja auch jemand aber da musst du schon mal nachfragen.
Ja genau so dann das war diese arbeit eigentlich so und dann irgendwann so einer der
aufmerksamer hörer des selber an der universität professor in bonn sagte zu mir mal auf so einer konferenz wo ich höre immer deinen podcast ich finde das ist doch schon wissenschaftlich warum gibt es denn nicht das als dekoration ab
das war schon so fortgeschrittenen september oder glaube ich september zweitausendsiebzehn da war ich schon also.
Da war ich sehr tief drin genau ne genau absolut ich hatte das überhaupt nicht geplant ich wusste zwar dass das was ich da mache.
Ist für mich ist es ist wissenschaft das ist dieser anspruch an dem ich das gemessen haben will und selber messe
es ist nicht irgendwas einfach nur zum spaß oder so es ist nicht nur ich spreche nicht einfach so wie ich alles mögliche andere auch machen könnte sondern ich habe das als wissenschaftliche arbeit begriffen,
und auch als wissenschaftliche darstellungsform ich habe das so entwickelt und so so verstanden und auch so also sagen so herausgefunden dass das in dieser bedeutung hat aber als,
qualifikationslauf arbeit das ist ja nochmal was anderes sagt er ja reicht es doch ein hab ich gesagt du spinnst ja völlig wo.
Wo denkst du hin wer wer nimmt sowas an und das war tatsächlich auch eine gewisse frage bis ich dann aber kannte ich schon früher auf
also ich war vorher schon auch sagen in kontakt mit stefan bronko
noch ins gespräch kam und stefan professor hier für text theorie und gestaltung an der universität der künste in berlin
arbeitet auch unter anderem mit sprachnotizen mit whatsapp-nachrichten mit,
zu seinen vorlesungen beispielsweise und ich kannte das diese art der arbeit und ich dachte das würde ihn interessieren dass professor,
theorie und gestaltung das ist doch kern seiner beschäftigung unter anderem das schlag ich doch mal vor und ja.
Fand das plausibel und so hat sich das dann entwickelt dass das als promotions projekt weiterentwickelt wurde.
Die promotions ordnung sah dann tatsächlich vor dass man einen geschriebenen text abgibt das war mir erstmal natürlich.
Ja
Das lag mir jetzt erstmal nicht nahe der text ist gesprochen.
Ich wollte ohnehin experimentell so ein bisschen damit arbeiten was passiert eigentlich wenn ich kann ich das transkribieren lassen
ja
ich will das nicht selber also menschlich will ich das nicht transkribieren lassen und so aber wie mache ich wie schließe ich mir so wie wie entsteht auch so ein ein zugang,
zu dem material zu den gesprochenen texten wie mache ich die durchsucht wie finde ich worüber ich da gesprochen habe ich habe ein paar schlagworte ich habe das ab
monat drei oder so habe ich begonnen das zu verschlagwortet die folgen aber das ist natürlich nur so lose aus dem gedächtnis im anschluss an die folge
die kleinen episodenbeschreibungen haben auch nicht viel hergegeben also wie finde ich worüber ich jemals gesprochen habe wie finde ich das wieder wie arbeite ich damit also habe ich mir auch darüber gedanken gemacht und dann habe ich mich für technische lösungen interessiert ich habe dann eine gewisse zeit
also sehr viel zeit viel zu viel zeit mit dragon diktiere software mich herum geärgert
die es für grau in haft niemanden zu empfehlen und die hat aber die funktion theoretisch zumindest dass man da eine datei
einlädt die liest das in ich glaube vierfacher oder achtfacher geschwindigkeit aus und transkribiert den text ohne punkt und komma als blogs hat.
Macht aber keine zeit marken.
Macht keine zeit marken erkennt nicht alles nicht fehlerfrei und stürzt bei jeder zweiten folge ab.
Auch noch okay.
Also ich habe das ich habe das für vierzig folgen gemacht.
Und immer mal wieder versucht auch zu überarbeiten aber das war einfach,
eine gängige lösung ich wollte eine lösung die sagen schmerzfrei funktioniert.
Musste nicht absolut hundert prozent korrekt sein das musste nicht jedes einzelne wort und jede aussprache und so genau sein weil man im sprechen man schluckt,
vorteile und so weiter das war aber egal es muss ja ungefähr,
durchsucht bar sein und da gab's über auf honig die lösung dass sich das über google hab transkribieren können auf honig macht die ja die verhackt stückelung also die streckensicherung in einzelnen abschnitte und sequenzielle wird das dann an,
so die google geschickt die wiederum dann ein fertiges transkript zurückgibt.
Das kann man auch mit anderen services machen als mit google aber ich wählte google und witt.
Ich habe beide services ausgewählt und beides quasi machen lassen die
manche ergebnisse waren besser ich fand das von google in der regel ein bisschen verlässlicher zwar nicht wirklich verlässlich aber es hat mir einen text mit dem ich hab arbeiten können gebracht,
und dann dachte ich vielleicht reicht ja das wenn ich das abgebe als die situation.
Immerhin text jetzt.
Sagt ja keiner dass man das selber geschrieben haben.
Sagte er keiner ja in den verhandlungen stellte sich dann raus dass es dass es möglicherweise schon eine arge zumutung wäre.
Und wenn ich jetzt nicht das verfahren komplett ändern sollte dann zeigt doch zumindest einen kleinen text schreiben das lag mir nahe weil ich wollte über dieses sprechen da denken tatsächlich auch nochmal den versuch machen so als weitere drehung.
Ein zu schreiben weil die die die eben wenn man der these glaubt wenn man seinen eigenen experiment traut und sagt,
die darstellungsform ist nicht beliebig
die verändert die macht etwas mit der erkenntnis dann lohnt es sich das nochmal zu drehen,
zu fragen wenn ich jetzt im sprechenden denken eine form des denkens entwickeln
konnte die ein eigenen eine eigene darstellungsform eine eigene durchführung eine erkenntnis eigener art und so weiter betrifft gestaltet wie kann ich das aufgreifen für ein wissenschaftliches schreiben
ein schreiben das nicht so tut als gäbe es dieses sprechen nicht sondern ein schreiben dass das in rechnung stellt
das also mit reflektiert und so weiter und darüber nachdenken und dann habe ich mir drei begriffe rausgenommen zu denen ich schreiben wollte das einmal bei den begriff des selbstgespräche
einmal den begriff des experimentalfilm systems und dann die unterscheidung von sprechenden denken und schreiben dem denken.
Und in dieser dann sind da drei aufsätze entstanden ursprünglich dachte ich schreibe so ein kleines.
Vierzig seiten oder so aber dann habe ich den sommer durchgeschrieben und es mir sind noch dinge eingefallen und so und dann wurde es eben.
Zweihundert seiten.
Damit jetzt hier keine konfusion entsteht wo es nicht angemessen ist also deine dissertation die du ja von anfang an.
Also das thema war stand auch schon fest eigentlich und das war aber jetzt was anderes eigentlich das war was genau das war diese mit über religion und.
Genau religiöse und wissenschaftliche wahrheit unter bedingungen des internets ein genau soziologische medien theoretische arbeit die sich mit eben solchen medien veränderungen in ganz konkreten gegenständen befasst nicht mit dem sprechenden denken.
Und das neben vielen anderen sachen ist das was du quasi so über dieses jahr hinweg täglich in diesem podcast ausgerollt hast und den prozess sozusagen sichtbar gemacht hast wie du dir darüber gedanken gemacht hast und dann.
Dann dieses gesprochene denken.
In einer automatisiert verschriftlichen form also in diesen transkript die dann automatisch erstellt wurden und
wo du wahrscheinlich zu viel energie reingesteckt hat die noch groß zu korrigieren und was meine theoretisch auch noch machen könnte sozusagen also wie auch immer.
Wurde dann quasi als doktorarbeit anerkannt.
Um um genau zu sein nicht mal nur in dieser verschriftlichen form sondern eingereicht habe ich quasi diese drei.
Aber der das erste kapitel also ich man muss es in buchform einreichen also und das ist für podcaster natürlich schon ein bisschen herausforderung mach mal ein buch draus.
So wie macht man das.
Wie macht man das mit der bindung und.
Ja genau also ich habe halt diese geschrieben und dann kapitel also der einleitung vorwort schießmichtot die ganzen sachen und dann kapitel eins
selbstgespräche da habe ich geschrieben selbstgespräche wurden kontinuierlich veröffentlicht unter podcast punkt radio punkt eu da war mein dir war der podcast zu finden sie sind alle online.
Guckt hier dass es die referenz dass es was ich hier als ersten hauptteil einreiche und dann habe ich halt eine sd-karte eingeklebt.
Wo die ganzen transkript drauf war.
Nee wo die audiofiles drauf waren.
Ich habe die audiofiles für den fall dass man nicht weiß wie man podcast bedienen kann man die sich halt anhören ja so und das war das war der hauptteil.
Eine url und eine sd karte.
So genau so und und dann kam 's halt noch ein zweiter teil das waren diese drei aufsätze die ich geschrieben hatte.
Und dann war noch und dann habe ich noch einen anhang geschrieben.
Der anfang war so eine kleine dokumentation aber das war jetzt wirklich nur so sprach wie kam ich zu den transkript was habe ich mir da überlegt und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann habe ich ebenfalls auf den auf der sd-karte als anhang zum anhang zum anfang sozusagen noch die transkript mit mitgegeben,
diese dreitausendsechshundert zeiten transkript die allerdings auch schon auf der website sind also die sind ja schon über
publisher eingebunden und verlinkt sodass man in den.
Auf der webseite im player selber sagen suchen kann nach bestimmten begriffen und man findet die stelle dann und klickt da drauf und dann geht's da los an der stelle wo ich darüber gesprochen hatte also diese ganze magie das pottler publisher muss ich dir nicht erzählen aber.
Kann ich mal wieder an der stelle erwähnen also großartige funktionen und wir waren auch wir wir waren auch in kontakt
als ich das vorbereitet hatte dass ich das so ein paar funktionen das war damals noch in der version diese transkript version und so wie das funktionieren mir war das einbindet und so ein paar technische probleme noch zu lösen
gewesen aber das ging und jetzt ist das also ohnehin schon die transkripts sind schon da ja genau und man kann das durchsuchen,
man kann auch ganz viele andere dinge damit machen also es schließen sich noch ganz viel andere experimente an,
soziologe und freund hier der wohnt in berlin arbeitet in bonn an der universität,
der beschäftigt sich unter anderem mit topic modeling also so computerbasierter auswertungsverfahren von großer texte und so weiter.
Und der bat mich eines tages mal um das transkript archiv meiner podcast folgen und dann habe ich ihm gegeben und dann hat der so mit peißen so
topic model links also erstmal so eine matrix wort matrix und so daraus erstellt und dann verschiedene verschiedene
eben ein ein so ein bestimmtes topic modeling verfahren drüber an anwenden können
und dieses topic modeling nur ganz kurz ich verstehe auch nicht alles aber unter anderem erzeugt das so computer generierte themen
cluster also wort cluster eigentlich die da die da computer selber also diese diese algorithmen selber als thema modellieren
die nennen das topic null bis neunzehn im fall hier war es so ein topic modeling von zwanzig topics und sagte ich so
hier ist eine ein errechnete zusammenhang zwischen diesen worten die tauchen besonders häufig zusammen auf und dann war es interessant zu sehen welche themen der computer so als themen vorschlägt ohne.
Also was was er meint worüber gesprochen wurde zwar.
Und das war tatsächlich
unglaublich faszinierend also es waren zwanzig zwanzig verschiedene themen und ich habe mir das angeguckt,
diese blöcke und manche davon waren wirklich sehr präzise herausfinden ware themen die sich
die sich da herauskristallisiert haben im verlauf der der folgen also dieses topic modeling sieht vor dass die themen quasi zu einem gewissen prozentsatz in allen folgen auftreten müssen und in manchen zu bei sehr
dominant sind.
Immer ein beispiel für so einen topic was dann dabei benannt wurde also benennt die software das vollständig oder sagte nur hier ist ein toppic und jetzt gib mir mal eine bezeichnung dafür also.
Also es gibt zum beispiel eines des hat er eben keinen titel sondern das nennt topic null bis neunzehn,
aber es gibt dann wort cluster in worte an in bestimmter häufigkeit in bestimmter wichtigkeit für dieses top,
und eines beispielsweise wäre als habe ich jetzt hier beispielsweise topic zwölf das hab ich arbeit genannt.
Da ist das erste wort arbeit das zweite stelle geld arbeiten konferenz universität sachen möglicherweise.
Jahre praktisch bekommen sogar handarbeiten nochmal klein geschrieben computer uni institut konferenzen und so weiter.
Also arbeiten an der uni da kann ich mich auch erinnern gab es ein paar folgen wo du das intensiv thematisiert hast die reise nach witten und wieder zurück und wie viel zeit das kostet und also nur sachen.
Ein anderes thema das habe ich sprechen das denken eins genannt es gibt zwei themen zum sprechenden denken das ist besteht aus den worten sprache sprechen denken denken großgeschrieben gespräch spricht darüber sprechen.
Schrift hören selbst gespräch geht satz selber publikum beispielsweise stimme gedanken.
Und das ist so ein cluster es bietet das mir an es gibt natürlich auch andere die habe ich zum beispiel ballaststoffe genannt.
Ballaststoffe etwa thema es besteht aus den worten ja mal einfach.
Podcast bisschen heute vielleicht tag wirklich sagen gut weil warum dinge glaube morgen interessiert möchte darüber gesagt.
Und und das sind ballaststoffe
die sind notwendig ganz offensichtlich notwendig um vollständige sätze bilden zu können und manchmal fällt einem nichts ein dann ist diese folge voll von ballaststoffen sozusagen
ausscheidungsprodukte
sprachlich ein so das interessante jetzt aber an diesem topic modelling ist ja unter anderem nicht nur einfach dass er lustige wörter zusammenstellen und denkt das ist ein thema sondern ist dass du dann verlauf
entwicklungen dieser themen nachzeichnen kannst und bei einer so großen menge und über so ein ganzes jahr von hundertvierundvierzig stunden ist es ja schon interessant wie haben sich diese themen eigentlich entwickelt und dann lässt sich zum beispiel zeigen dass was ich
ballaststoffe genannt habe was so eine sprechen über dieses ich podcaste hier.
Tendenziell von anfang des jahres bis zum ende des jahres abgenommen hat also ich habe immer weniger darüber gesprochen dass ich hier ein podcast mache und so.
Hm
Weil es wurde immer weniger wichtig wichtiger wurden die themen und das sprechende denken ist sondern kontinuierlich wichtiger geworden also die reflexion über das diesen begriff des sprechens.
Selbst so das entwickelt er sich dann
es gibt dann andere ein ein thema das mir zum beispiel sehr unangenehm ist oder mit dem ich mich,
anfreunden kann aber das natürlich gleichwohl wichtig ist das nenne ich heiße luft oder chargon der eigentlichkeit,
das ist ein thema null in dem fall und es besteht aus wörtern wie
eigentlich eben immer schon ganz einfach ja mal mehr überhaupt frage gar form weil heute geht irgendwie sagen natürlich gerade,
und dieses eigentlich und das allerwichtigste ist gar nicht erkannt weil das ist in der transformation fast immer nicht erkannt worden ist sozusagen ich sage viel zu oft sozusagen und das sind so floskeln zu kleine partikel sprachliche partikel die eingebunden sind.
Immer in den momenten in denen ich darüber nachdenke aber mir nicht sicher bin so eine verzögerung einbauen möchte.
Na so ein wort sondern so ein platzhalter eigentlich ne.
Und so eine eigentlichkeit einbaut also eigentlich will ich ja das sagen aber ich weiß nicht eigentlich geht's mir darum ich mir geht's jetzt gar nicht darum ich denke also laut nach
ich spreche mit mir und ich entwickelt in dem moment warum das da geht und ständig
unterbreche ich mich und sage nein eigentlich geht's mir um was anderes und ständig kommt dieses eigentlich sozusagen quasi und so weiter und das sind so markierungen von.
Oder auch.
Oder auch ja oder auch.
Das finde ich sowieso ich hatte irgendwann mal ich hatte irgendwann mal so ein.
Ein podcast indem man gesprächspartner wirklich viel das bemüht hat oder überhaupt generell so verschleppung hatte und da fehlt es mir dann irgendwie selber auch mal auf ich habe da so eine gewisse grund toleranz.
Und dann dachte ich mir so jetzt guckst du mal.
Was kannst du diesen podcast jetzt im schneidprozess gutes tun ist vielleicht ist er vielleicht besser.
Wenn ich jetzt hier das messer nehme und da mal dran rum schneide und da ist mir dann.
In diesem prozess auch schon mal was klar geworden nämlich.
Das er ist nicht gleich dass er ja also es gab.
Mindestens drei verschiedene arten von s.
Es gab so reine zeit schaffer ja die so ein bisschen so ein.
Nachdenken in gewisser hinsicht auch machen es gab müssen korrigieren des wo man nicht so genau.
Wo man eher ausdrückt sodass man noch nicht so ganz an dem punkt angekommen bist wo man hin will und gab auch so weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau also so bindende.
Die den wort fluss und die die melodie des des der gedanken vollkommen zerstört haben wenn wenn ich die rausgenommen habe also es gab sie kann man killen.
Rein zeitlichen strecker irgendwie die mache ich auch heute noch teilweise mal raus mir denkst,
muss jetzt nicht immer noch mal eine sekunde gestreckt werden hier alles aber hätte ich jetzt konsequent so eine anti-faschistinnen die alle einfach nimmt und sagt er sind doof weg zack bumm dann entfremdet sich auf einmal.
Das ergebnis und das ist auch so ein ding was ich bei so radio beiträgen auch oft merke.
Der keller ist ja irgendwie richtig
krass am start und dann hat man so ein schwerer hechelnd atmende.
Wo leute einem irgendwie mit einer dichte auch entgegenschlagen die dann das hirn irgendwie gar nicht mehr so richtig.
Einsortiert bekommen weil ihm einfach die eigene rhythmik
und eigene zeitlich zeit irgendwie komplett genommen wurde und man hat sozusagen auf dem auf dem altar der verständlichkeit eigentlich genau diese verständlichkeit wieder geopfert.
Das ist ganz interessante erkenntnis gewesen wie sehr sozusagen das sprechen in dem moment auch mit dem gedanken und mit dem was man vermitteln möchte eigentlich auch zusammenhängt.
Es gibt eine ganz schöne folge von fünf minuten gmbh ist ein podcast der gesellschaft wirtschaftskr,
kommunikations instituts an der universität der künste da stellt sich das vor und in fünf minuten beiträgen werden da eben wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler am gehweg interviewt.
Und die fragen sind rausgeschnitten und sogar gelegentlich
das atmen und man hat dann zum beispiel die folge von thomas düller der zweit gutachter war bei meinem bei meiner arbeit die habe ich mir angehört interesse interesse halbe man hört fünf minuten ihn sprechen und er atmet nicht ein einziges mal und man hört keinen schnitt,
und man wird wahnsinnig man wird.
Man wird schlicht wahnsinnig man denkt sich immer fällt vom stuhl man kriegt selber schon atem probleme man denkt sich so ich kriege keine luft mehr kriege dabei bin ich nur am hören ich könnte ja mal nicht will aber beim zuhören ich kriege schon keine luft mehr da nur durch diese zuhören es ist so.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nur so ein extremer fall aber bei radio beiträgen das stimme ich dir völlig zu da ist das oft so geglättet die sprache so verdichtet und so viel nachbearbeitet oder es wird
gesprochen wie gedruckt weil der text vorher geschrieben war also man liest den ab ja und so weiter also.
All diese formen gibt es ja auch von konstruktion von radio beiträgen und manchmal geschieht das in einer,
manchmal geschieht das in einer in einer brauchbaren vorm,
manchmal allerdings nicht und dann wird werden so verdichtete verdichtete beiträge produziert die die es einem sehr schwer machen mit so einem gespräch modus zuzuhören.
Weil man nicht mehr mitdenken kann und das ist wenn es ist ja auch so eine so eine viel kolportierte kritik.
An podcast ich meine an uns prallt das so ein bisschen ab aber die diskussion kommt ja immer wieder absolut ja,
das gelaber oder dass dass die länge und da ist ja viel drin was eigentlich gar keine information trägt und ne also so eine kritik an dieser länge und darreichungsform wo ich dann.
Eigentlich mal sagen muss naja.
Es wird halt nicht also man kann kosmetische maßnahmen machen klar und da irgendwie so einen lippenstift drauf ziehen aber eigentlich gewinnt man nicht so sehr viel davon weil mit jeder sekunde die man killt.
Nimmt man ja auch so ein sub signal aus dieser botschaft heraus was irgendwie immer so so eine träger frequenz.
Auf die man sich denke ich relativ unbewusst.
Rauf synchronisiert und wo man.
Die geschwindigkeit des gegenübers auch einfach über eine wenn man wenn man es richtig macht und kann manche leute haben ja schwierigkeiten und können sehr viel besser informationen über text aufnehmen die hadern dann generell so mit mit podcast aber ich denke dass viele leute die podcast hören entdeckt haben ist.
Dass ein.
Die geschwindigkeit des podcast in gewisser hinsicht auch runter getaktet so in so einen so einen so einen ruhepuls moment bringt und ich selber habe das zuhören.
War früher auch so so ein quatsch dampfer die ganze zeit sich daran erfreut hat sich selber hin zu hören und und und an anderen leuten so aufzudrängen und in dieser illusion gelebt dass jede sekunde
akustischer raum den den ich jetzt belege zu meiner eigenen wichtigkeit beiträgt typisches jugend problem sicherlich und.
Das vergeht einerseits so ein bisschen mit der zeit aber es verging dann auch als ich dann freund viele interessante diskussionen hatte.
Der unfassbar langsam spricht und mich hat es ist wahnsinnig gemacht dachte man so ich muss jetzt aber wieder drückt schon wieder in mir heraus so ich muss muss jetzt irgendwas liefern.
Es war eine gnade dass dass er sich wiederum von meiner hektik niemals aus der ruhe bringen lassen sondern einfach seinen takt einfach gnadenlos durchgezogen hat was irgendwann sich dann so sehr auf mich niedergelegt hat es mir dachte so ok scheiß drauf ist.
Einfach mal schon auszuhalten ist jetzt nutzt du mal die zeit.
Die die eigentlich quasi kostenfrei angeboten wird durch das langsame sprechen und diese pausen und bist nicht der meinung müsste es jetzt das wäre eine qualität diese lücke zu füllen.
Dann.
Ich höre es einfach besser zu einerseits und nutzt die zeit dann einfach auch ganz praktisch um schon mal darüber nachzudenken was man denn dann vielleicht sagt wenn's dann dann an der zeit ist und das hat mir dann sozusagen auch das zuhören.
Erleichtert oder überhaupt
reporting moment so dass ihr das gefühl hat so ich fange jetzt langsam an überhaupt mal zuzuhören und gutes zuhören denke ich wiederum ist dann wiederum auch die basis um überhaupt ordentlich reden zu können weil wenn man einfach nur so daher schwafel dann.
Ist ja für andere leute auch einfach total uninteressant also abgesehen davon fühlt sich ja leute auch nicht ernst genommen wenn man.
Ihnen zuhört et cetera also hängt eine ganze menge dran also das ist sozusagen alles was.
Mir jetzt gerade dazu noch einfällt.
Ich wollte nur mal ganz kurz auf diese vielleicht ein bisschen zurückrollen weil wir waren ja jetzt gerade dabei sozusagen deine dissertation und wie sie aufgebaut war.
Und diese darreichungsform in so einer ton schrift kombination die halt.
Anders ausgelegt war als man das erste mal gemeinhin kennt also erstmal gab's halt ton.
Gut vielleicht hat es schon mal jemand gemacht das haben wir nochmal so einen podcast oder so eine audioaufnahmen noch zusätzlich geliefert hat aber hier dreht sich ja quasi.
Sozusagen genau in die andere richtung erst war der ton dann kam der text.
Und der ton nimmt ja dann in form der eingeklebt karte auch so primär was auf dadurch dass man das dann aber das das das originaldokument ist und man dann eben.
Diese gedanken zeitlich genau injizieren kann und jetzt eben diese text wüste hat auch wenn die vielleicht nur zu fünfundneunzig prozent gut ist und
da könnte man ja dann auch noch mal schauen ob es nochmal was bringt überhaupt das auch nochmal zu bearbeiten das würde man es crowd mäßig oder vielleicht in fünf jahren mit noch besseren transkriptionen,
kann ja auch noch mal besser werden ne sich das nochmal neu anschaut so aber man gewinnt jetzt auch für die wissenschaft an der stelle eine komplett neue achse der auswertung.
Ich hätte das jetzt eh schon gefragt wenn du nicht damit angekommen bist in dieser klasse auswählen ich habe das ich habe ja auch so einen podcast wo,
transkribiert ist da kam auch schon mal jemand anderes eine klasse auswertung gemacht das war nur so ein bisschen so pi mal daumen mal zu gucken was denn so.
Das ging ja nicht so weit dass dann wirklich so themenbereiche lokalisiert worden aber es war schon mal so weit dass die auswertung sagen konnte welche podcasts in dieser serie mit welchen anderen wohl in verbindung standen.
Also dass man darüber dann sozusagen automatisch oder so halb automatisch so ein index der vernetzung der gedanken
darlegen kann das hält bei deinem port lockt dann eigentlich noch sehr viel weitreichendere.
Was ja schon selber in diesem zeitlichen verlauf dargestellt so erst habe ich darüber geredet dann habe ich darüber gerade dieses thema wurde dann
immer irgendwie wichtiger und könnte ja dann im prinzip auch irgendwann dazu führen dass wenn man das jetzt noch etwas weiter präzisiert und dann wirklich auch so zeit links macht und sagte hier fängt dann dieses thema in diesem podcast auch an und da hört's irgendwie auf also
nicht nur die sendung selber so als abgeschlossenen bereich zu betrachten sondern eben vielleicht auch.
Kapitel bereiche oder entdeckt selber wann das thema sich innerhalb
einer sendung geändert hat und dann könnte man halt eben schnell auch zu so einem halber link modus kommen wo man sich wirklich sozusagen so aha dieser art gedanke
war vor drei wochen das erste mal da so spring doch mal dahin so dass man eben so auch so ein so ein thematisch gefühltes nachhören
darüber auch implementieren kann das natürlich dann.
Platz ja schon der kopf in dem moment wenn man darüber nachdenkt wie man auf einmal über sowas wenn man über gedanken nachdenken kann.
Also absolut stimmig völlig zu da platzt einem der kopf mehrfach ist er mir auch schon geplatzt also ich darüber nachgedacht hatte,
ich weiß nicht ob ich vorhin den namen erwähnt hatte wer das gemacht hat dieses topic modeling stefan priester wollte ich auf keinen fall den namen unterschlagen haben.
Stefan priester macht es den kann man sicherlich auch anschreiben und fragen was und wie er das gemacht hat das waren so seine ersten experimente damit aber schon sehr sehr brauchbar und in der tat diese durchsucht zeit
dieser referentin,
diese wechselseitige verknüpfbar von themen also nicht nur so im sinne von hörerinnen die dieses thema gut fanden mögen vielleicht auch xy was natürlich auch eine hilfreicher nebeneffekt sein kann,
dass das vergleichbar wird in einer art und weise einen zugang der eben auch früher.
Der schon quantitativ nicht möglich waren aber hier auch noch mal eine ganz neue qualitäts- ne mit reinbringt in dieses in diese fragen und,
jetzt noch so als kleiner rückschritt zu also nochmal zurück zu diesem dissertations- projekt weil dieses topic modeling ist ja offensichtlich schon die erste wissenschaftliche anschluss untersuchung
zu dieser wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen noch bevor jetzt das buch erscheint was nächstes jahr erscheint werbung hier schon mal aber.
Bist du auch der sd-karte eingeklebt.
Ja dass die leserinnen und leser dieses buches wissen natürlich wie man podcast bedient.
Die wissen wie man es findet aber,
aber also das ist schon die erste wissenschaftliche anschluss untersuchung die sich daraus ermöglicht
aus den aus den fragen und aber auch aus diesem zugang dieses transkribieren bei dem transkript
war mir tatsächlich wichtig nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie formale vorgaben einer promotions ordnung erfülle und deswegen transkribieren ich das ich wollte erstmal schauen was ist eigentlich technisch möglich ich wollte das eben nicht menschlich transkribieren.
Man kann da irgendwie leute könnten das transkript verbessern will ich gar nicht ich wollte ich wollte tatsächlich den stand der der möglichkeiten jetzt
was ist verlässlich möglich ohne großen aufwand also deswegen google ist sein die beste adresse amazon wäre noch besser weil es soll besser sein und.
Aber damals gab es noch keine.
Viel in dem markt also ich denke da werden wir in den nächsten jahren große fortschritte.
Ja das finde ich großartig so aber zu dem zeitpunkt gab es einfach zwei adressen die ich hab verlässlich adressieren können und es war mit und google
und google hat die etwas besseren ergebnisse geliefert und sie hatten so ein ein programm wo man dreihundert dollar spielzeug,
bekommt wenn man sich anmeldet für diese cloud-plattform und diese dreihundert dollar habe ich leider eigentlich sprengen müssen
also ich hätte den geldhahn müssen musste ich aber nicht weil ich habe das alles über auf honig angereicht
und auch von nick hat das immer so im set von zwanzig folgen geschickt und das ging so schnell bei google rein dass die das vorher ausgespuckt hatten die ergebnisse bevor sie festgestellt haben dass sie schon gar kein geld mehr hatte.
Überraschenderweise genau dreihundert dollar verbraucht die ich nicht bezahlt habe also für die transaktion aller folgen
auf einen schlag war sehr sehr gut dass das so funktioniert hat aber eben es war also ein es ist es dokumentiert den stand der möglichkeiten.
Zu diesem zeitpunkt als ich dieses projekt gemacht habe und dieses experiment ich wollte also wissen,
ich da sprechen arbeite wissenschaftlich und das als methode hier entwickelt
was ist möglich an durchsucht barer
text produktion hier wie kann ich mit diesen audioaufnahmen wirklich weiterarbeiten und was ist realistisch machbar und dazu musste das eine technische lösung sein die das mit einem klick quasi mir transkribiert und einbindet und durch super macht und so weiter und das hatte ich darüber bekommen also diese diese
dieser stand der forschung und alles was ich jetzt so verbessern lässt am transkript und so weiter ist jetzt zumindest wissenschaftlich betrachten
nutzer und und aber auch selbst experimental toren aus der experimenta toren perspektive ist natürlich nochmal eine andere frage ich möchte vielleicht genauer in meinen texten arbeiten können aber für mich als als als experimental system als ein abgeschlossene,
experiment war wichtig den stand zu dokumentieren
der technischen möglichkeiten der transkriptionen der automatisierten transkriptionen von solchen audiofiles um zu schauen was geht eigentlich was kann ich da so an arbeit
damit erreichen und da ging schon ganz schön viel.
Und und dann schließen sich diese ganzen fragen an also was was arbeitet man damit weiter wie.
Kann man sich auch selber dann in zukunft in seinem material bewegen weil es fällt ja dann doch eine menge an material an
aber gleiches gilt ja auch für texte ja wenn man sich überlegt was der computer hier an an möglichkeiten eröffnet hat für wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler die texte geschrieben
früher schon geschrieben aber jetzt auf computern schreiben und dann digitalisiert wenn sie glück haben und der verlag ihnen pdf gibt es digitalisiert wieder vorliegen haben also die durchsucht des eigenen geschriebenen,
es ist ja ein weit verbreiteter irrtum anzunehmen dass die autorinnen und autoren genau wissen worüber sie geschrieben haben in dem moment wo man es geschrieben hat hat man es auch schon wieder vergessen,
keine ahnung was ich da geschrieben habe ich muss es auch wieder lesen oder eben ich öffne meinen computer und und und such,
mach einfach 'ne schlechte texture das mache ich bei geschriebenen wie bei gesprochenen texten heute.
Also das ist auf jeden fall sehr schön zu sehen dass es
podcast sozusagen auch mal diese schwelle genommen haben und jetzt zumindest schon mal ein prototyp da ist für man kann auch,
doktor einfach machen indem man einfach nur schreibt und einfach nur redet und dann quasi google schreiben lässt
bemerkenswert jetzt hast du aber das haben wir ja schon erwähnt also du hast.
Dieses thema erarbeitet das den podcast dazu verwenden um dieses thema zu erarbeiten dann ist das sozusagen als solches akzeptiert worden doktor wird irgendwie demnächst verliehen nämlich mal an wenn das alles veröffentlicht ist.
Diese zusätzlichen kapitel die wir jetzt noch dazu geschrieben hast die waren ja dann aber dann quasi die meter erkenntnis aus dem podcast projekt selber.
Der interessante part finde ich ist ja jetzt sozusagen diese erkenntnislage über dieses.
Du es genannt hast sprechende denken und.
Das schreibende.
Wer sich schon mal so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hat wie man so plant was man in so ein mikrofon spricht kennt das wahrscheinlich wenn man.
Es gibt ja nichts langweiligeres als deutsche wissenschaftler die vorträge erhalten weil sie dazu tendieren was aufzuschreiben und dann im schlimmsten fall,
es vorlesen oder im allerschlimmsten fall ist auf einem light packen und dann vorlesen das ist ja sozusagen dass das allerschlimmste aber der eigentliche schlimme teil dabei ist schon dass man schreibt weil.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht so auf diese leute los aber es ist generell so es gibt halt einfach,
eine art und weise zu schreiben fürs reden und zu schreiben fürs,
lesen,
das ist auch kein grund neue erkenntnis wenn man ja sowieso radio medien ausbildung macht und so weiter da gibt's ja doch noch anschläge literatur das kriegt er jeder sozusagen um die ohren geknallt dass es eben dieses schreiben fürs,
sprechen auch gibt und das ja so das was vom radio auch normalerweise zum einsatz kommt.
Weil ich auch finde also so ganz scheint es noch nicht den nagel auf den kopf getroffen zu haben weil die ansprache die man so aus dem radio kennt ist.
Mein geschmack der dann doch immer noch auf eine gewisse art und weise hölzern oder zu sehr geführt oder was du kannst doch nicht so gar nicht so genau konkretisieren was war denn jetzt sozusagen.
Deine erkenntnisse über diesen prozess was das das das gesprochene.
Also ein denkprozess in einem sprechproblemen abbildet was.
Was sind da so die faktoren die die da zum tragen kommen und inwiefern unterscheidet sich das eben in diesem denkprozess den man im text.
Darlegt.
Ja ich fange mal bei der bei dem,
bei dem beispiel an dass du gerade zum schluss nochmal genannt hast nämlich das schreiben und sprechen fürs radio und wie das dann klingt wie das wie das dann sich anhört wenn man radio hört
das ist auch eine erfahrung die ich oft gemacht habe bei radio wenn texte in einer form gesprochen werden die
geschrieben wurden aber im stil mündlich daherkommen sollen
also so in so einem mündlichen auch eben möglicherweise einen persönlich ansprechen sollen und sofort.
Dann hat man aber aufgrund der produktionsbedingungen im radio eben das heißt die schere bei r s und m und so fort
ein so hochverdichtetes text dass er einen ständig mit so einer,
extremen aufmerksamkeitsfokussierung gegenübertritt also der kommt
als wäre es das allerwichtigste hör mir zuhören niemandem sonst zu.
Am besten du hörst sofort auf auto zu fahren auch wenn du adio am besten beim autofahren hören willst.
Egal halt an hör mir zu so ist diese art und weise dieses sprechens die hat so eine extreme aufmerksamkeit gestus
eben weil sie so dicht weil sie so weil sie so wenig mündlich weil sie so wenig zögerlich ist weil sie weil sie oft befreit dass man dass man das so sehen und anders sehen kann
genau weiß ob man sich seiner sache so sicher ist radio moderatorinnen und radiomoderatoren ist diese unsicherheit zwar vertraut aber davon lassen sie einem nichts hören.
Ich würde sagen es hat einen mangel an redundanz wenn man so ein.
So ein qr-code auf dem plakat wo sich am anfang immer alle gefragt haben wer würde denn das benutzen ich glaube mittlerweile ist jedem klar wenn man so ein.
Code erzeugt dann kann man bei der erzeugung.
Die resonanz niveau.
Kann man es ganz genau wie viel wie fehler darf man sozusagen bei der wahrnehmung dieser information machen und dass man trotzdem noch irgendwie die eigentliche kerninformation mal rausbekommen
dieser redundanz leider der scheint in dem radio moment relativ weit links.
Ja also der soziologe niklas luhmann den ich ja vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt hatte der wird auch nachgesagt,
ich habe es nicht selbst beim gelesen aber im nachsagen hören dass er mal gesagt hat eine gute vorlesung oder gute vorlesung vortrag hat siebzig prozent redundanz dreißig prozent neues.
Das gilt eigentlich für alle arten von texten wenn man sie denn so in irgendeiner form anschlussfähigen gestalten möchte außer die textform selber ist jetzt tatsächlich auf verdichtung hin.
Ausgerichtet
und und versucht deswegen etwas anderes und das muss man meines erachtens schon ernst nehmen oder ist dann eine konsequenz die sich daraus entwickeln lässt also aus dem sprechenden denken lernt man auch etwas über dieses schreiben
und den unterschied von sprechen und schreiben in dieser form also lassen sich jetzt nicht.
Wenn man sprechen das denken als eine eigene form der darstellung und wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisproblem begreift und entwickelt also in einem solchen.
Vielleicht auch in einer formatvielfalt es muss ja nicht immer nur ein selbstgespräche podcast sein oder so sondern man kann das ja auch anwenden in kontexten in seminaren in vorträgen wie du's gesagt hast nicht schreiben sondern sprechen was passiert eigentlich wenn ich
vorlesungen so konzipiere wenn ich wenn ich die sein im gespräch selbst zu konstruieren versuche das kann auch manchmal schiefgehen keine frage,
aber das gehört dann auch dazu
auch daraus entwickelt sich erst überhaupt so eine praxis dass das sprechen dann denkens mit aber wenn wenn also ein solches sprechendes denken entwickelt ist oder entwickelt werden kann in der ganzen vielfalt der der formen was bedeutet das dann für ein schreiben.
Kann neue schreib räume entstehen neue formen des schreibens entstehen die zum beispiel die präzise anordnung von schrift zeichen,
auf dem hintergrund untergrund
von pixeln auf dem bildschirm und so weiter grafische anordnungen aber auch zum beispiel sehr präzise anordnungen von worten in bestimmten reihenfolge ohne,
information ohne stimme ernst nehmen wo es beispielsweise auf visuelle gleichzeitigkeiten ankommt.
Oder eben im hinblick auf
code also auf auf auf befehle die die dann sozusagen ausgeführt werden müssen in so bestimmten schlaufen und so weiter also also in solchen ganz anderen kontexten von schriftlichkeit nochmal zu denken
gibt es da nicht ganz neue methoden mittelweg einräume die sich öffnen,
weil sie jetzt befreit sind von all denen was ich im sprechen dann auch ballaststoffe nenne,
hier beispielsweise auch vorstellen als etwas was für sehr präzise kontexte
neue formen entwickelt gerade weil's jetzt ein sprechendes denken gibt das ist also es bricht so ein bisschen mit der vorstellung dass das sprechen etwas ist was vor der schrift da war und das hat mir schrift jetzt gehen wir einfach nur zurück zu dem was früher schon menschlich war.
Adorno hat das in einem kurzen tourismus in der minimal moralischer mal so genannt sagte also diese vorstellung dass die dass die sprache des menschen immer schon menschlich sein das sei es sozusagen eine lüge und man müsste die schrift sprache
also das schriftliche den distanz gewinn der wissenschaftliche distanz gewinn.
Durch das medium der schrift nun erstmal für dies für das sprechen für die mündliche sprache.
Aufheben also entwickeln darin quasi aufheben er hat dann geschrieben.
Dann lässt diese nicht durch regression auf die gesprochene sich widerrufen sondern nur in der konsequenz der strengsten sprachlichen objektivität
erst das sprechen dass die schrift in sich aufhebt befreit die menschliche rede von der lüge sie sei schon menschlich.
Das war jetzt aber ein gutes beispiel dafür dass die verdichtung des geschriebenen textes wieder der gesprochenen interpretation bedarf.
Deswegen redundanz erst die erst das sprechen dass die schrift,
die wortwahl die präzisen sprachlichen zeichen die verwendet werden können die entwickelt werden weil wir schrift hatten und das so haben schreiben können entwickeln können und so weiter erst.
Das sprechen dass die schrift in sich aufhebt befreit die menschliche rede schon immer menschlich zu sein.
Von dieser lüge immer schon menschlich zu sein also der der anspruch dass wir schon immer menschlich nur weil wir sprechen sei dieses sprechen schon ein menschliches das muss er sagen über reflexion gewinne der schriftlichkeit eine entwickelt werden
und umgekehrt gilt jetzt aber auch das gleiche für schrift.
Also wenn ein menschliches reden nun jetzt ein reden ist dass die schriftlichkeit schon in rechnung,
was also mit reflexion der wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisproblem beispielsweise.
Einen anderen politischen diskurs eine andere auseinandersetzung ermöglicht etwa ja also man kann anders miteinander sprechen.
Man kennt ja aus dem alltag sehr viele situationen indem man sehr wohl weiß dass nur weil wir miteinander sprechen ist es deswegen nicht schon menschlich sondern ganz im gegenteil aber möglicherweise bietet die schrift da ein ein variationsbezeichnung.
Für das sprechen der es einem erlaubt miteinander menschlicher zu sprechen als das vermeintlich schon menschliche sprechen,
immer schon ist also eine höfliche art und weise mag aber auch nicht nur höflich sein sondern eine sehr präzise
oder all diese debatten die wir führen bei antirassistischen antisexistisch und so weiter bemühungen sprache so zu verändern dass wir dass man nicht diskriminierend spricht
beispielsweise all solche formen sind diese reflexion gewinne die aufgehoben werden können ihn also aufbewahrt sozusagen
nutzbar gemacht werden fürs sprechen und umgekehrt aber jetzt auch also,
was heißt es wenn wir die erkenntnisse aus einem solchen entwickelten sprechen.
Jetzt nutzbar machen für ein schreiben und dann freiräume schaffen in denen plötzlich texten eine ganz andere funktion noch gewinnen kann als er sie zuvor hatte wenn er also nicht mehr diese ganzen ballaststoffe mit sich führen muss die man im sprechen auch haben kann.
Wenn man also für manches spricht für anderes schreibt ist das nicht so ein ein raum an freiheit,
für den text auch den noch anders zu entwickeln und was mich da interessiert sind natürlich unter anderem auch computerprogramme die geschrieben sind und so eine ganz andere art von schriftlichkeit aber auch eine ganz andere art von lesbarkeit fordern.
Die damit jetzt erstmal nichts zu tun hat aber in diesem zusammenhang kann man das stellen.
Verstehe ich dich jetzt richtig dass du das weiß ein bisschen komplex aber,
plädiert quasi oder du du zeigst auf oder denkst dass man sagen kann dass die präzision und klarheit von schrift und diese rolle die sie hat genau klar zu sein.
Dem.
Diesen mythos geschaffen hat das das das reden halt so die die menschliche lokale lockere art und weise ist obwohl es eben nicht stimmt wie man im alltag sehen kann.
Und das im umkehr schluss genauso sozusagen dass das das sprechen eben wiederum das schreiben.
Eigentlich auch in der hinsicht aufwertet zu etwas was es vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer erfüllt weil's auch nicht unbedingt immer so klar ist und weiß auch nicht unbedingt immer so präzise ist.
Und wie ich finde auch ein bisschen auch überhöht wird weil.
Es eigentlich dafür dass so klar ist.
Doch zu extrem viel missverständnissen führen wenn man sich die kommentar kultur zum beispiel zwischen blogs und podcast an.
Ort ja und wie viele missverständnisse blogs herbeirufen des markt
dem geschuldet sein dass die leute sich dann wenig zeit nehmen und einfach zack jetzt kann ich hier gleich kommentieren weil ich habe das mal quer gelesen oder ich habe mir mal gedacht gedacht was bastelt der titel vielleicht hier meint so aber eben auch so diese schwierigkeit dass das dass man eben das aus dem prozess den ich immer wieder festgestellt habe
wenn ich wenn ich was schreibe muss ich doppelt codieren ja ich muss einerseits meinen gedanken den ich jetzt in der regel.
Übers sprechen relativ einfach formulieren könnte.
So codieren dass er es erstmal korrekten satz ergibt der irgendwie mein mein formalien genügt so also rechtschreibung grammatik und dass auch das aussagt was ich gerne möchte aber ich muss trotzdem auch noch mit rein codieren.
Diese redundanz da ist ein coq code redundanz mit
ich muss missverständnisse vermeiden ich muss so schreiben ich muss so formulierungen finden muss es so drehen dass jetzt möglichst niemand missversteht
was jetzt aber dann am ende dann halt doch.
Das heißt man hat halt dieses problem also das ist so quasi so samoa moment so
modeliere quasi meinen gedanken in text aber wenn andere leute die dann für sich irgendwie dem modulieren verstehen sie am ende dann doch wieder was ganz
anderes weil es dann doch irgendwie nicht klar war was eigentlich hier unser unser code ist das man kann natürlich auch in der sprache missverstanden werden aber ich stelle einfach fest dass es eigentlich viel viel viel viel seltener also wenn man.
Sprache an sich beschäftigt und beherrscht und wenn man jetzt nicht aus so vollkommen des jungen kulturkreisen
kommt das mal eh die ganze zeit aneinander vorbei redet aber leute die sozusagen im wesentlichen unter derselben wolke sich bewegen wie ich,
dann doch schon einfacher die möglichkeit meine eigene das was ich eigentlich sagen möchte aus meiner sprache herauszuziehen.
Als beim text ist seine ich gebe mir extrem viel mühe und selbst wenn ich das tue dann ist es noch nicht mal sicher alles passiert.
Wie gesagt wenn man sich anschaut wieso das kommentar ergebnis am ende aussieht so bei blogs hauen sich alle irgendwie permanent in die fresse und,
ich will nicht sagen dass es jetzt nur blühende landschaften sind jetzt in podcast ist aber es ist schon spät schon in einer ganz anderen liga also das hat mir eigentlich immer gesagt okay da ist da ist dann sozusagen eigentlich auch ein
ein riesenvorteil im gesprochenen und ja jetzt ist natürlich die frage.
Kriegen wir unsere schriftliche kommunikation ist überhaupt noch zu retten und wie kriegen wir die sozusagen.
Mit mehreren und tanz angereichert um diese missverständnis ebene wegzubekommen.
Ja das ist dann das ist dann wirklich die frage also redundanz ist sicherlich ein wichtiger aspekt bei der bei bei diesem nachdenken darüber.
Aber nicht nur also weil beispielsweise die mündliche kommunikation ist voll von missverständnissen aber wenn man so will wir sind einfach bessere conceiler als so maschinen ja also wir sind einfach sehr viel fehler toleranter,
missverständnisse führen nicht immer zum programm abbruch.
Wir sind aber auch deshalb für toleranter weil einfach sehr viel mehr redundanz drin ist und zwar in form von betonung wie laut ich spreche wie ich sage wie schnell ich.
Ist aber nicht nur redundant also es ist einfach zum beispiel auch verschiedene und bild- und bedeutungslos ebenen also.
Anschaue dann steckt da vielleicht nicht diese freundlichkeit drin die ich in meiner stimme vermag zu also das ist dann nicht redundanz sondern das ist etwas neues etwas sagen es kommt informationsdichte ist er erhöht.
Bold und italic ja also ich ich ich kann halt durch so schreck schrift sagen ja in dem moment so ja das ist jetzt nicht so gemeint was ich in der stimme halt sofort intuitiv rüberbringen kann.
So
und die frage ist jetzt also wenn wir jetzt auf uns auf redundanz konzentrieren dann stellen wir zumindest mal fest dass ich sehr viele worte verwende und den podcast zu gestalten also dreitausendsechshundert zeiten das ist jetzt nicht wirklich eine praktikable buchlinge
ja
das kann man ja mal feststellen also das heißt wenn ich jetzt das als die erkenntnis meiner meiner wissenschaftliche arbeit begreife und dann nutzbar machen möchte für geschriebene texte dann würde ich einfach die aufblasen unnötig aufblasen es geht aber auch nicht um diesen aspekt.
Es geht nicht gar nicht um diesen aspekt
sondern vielleicht möglicherweise um ganz andere kriterien und da wird es interessant weil dann habe ich den eindruck beispielsweise dass das dieses sprechende denken
es ermöglicht über über fragen und aspekte von sprache und sprachlicher erkenntnis konstruktion nachzudenken die im schriftlichen anders aber auch erzeugt bar sind beispielsweise die brüchige zeit,
dieses zweifelnde momente der schleifen der schlaufe.
Aber auch dieses diese nicht ständig eine gewisse arrogante sicherheit über über den dingen schweben zu können und nur die ergebnisse produzieren zu können und das nur als wissenschaftliche texte begreifen lernen immer wieder in jedem wissenschaftlichen text diesen druck
des wissenschaftlichen schreibens zu reproduzieren erinnern in einer gewissen form auch immer wieder eine anmaßung die beispielsweise auch.
Einen größeren laienpublikum und publikum mehr und mehr stinkt ja also bei diesem wissenschaftlern die sind nicht nur unverständlich die glauben auch die ganze zeit die haben recht und ich verstehe das nicht das kann doch gar nicht sein das heißt nicht dass alles.
Allgemein verständlich formuliert sein muss
also dieser illusion ich bin kein anhänger dieser illusion ich weiß das gibt viele vertreterinnen und vertreter vieler fächer und disziplin die sagen wenn ich nicht klar und verständlich sagen kann dann ist es nicht richtig
das ist quatsch weil also viele theorien der physik oder der biologie oder chemie oder so
keinen plan würde ich nie nach also könnte ich vielleicht wenn ich mich irgendwie wenn ich studieren würde vielleicht wer weiß ja aber ich verstehe es nicht das heißt aber nicht dass sie falsch sind ich verstehe es halt nicht ja es ist halt sind halt komplizierte sache
müssen wir auch kompliziert also sie müssen hinreichend kompliziert aber so einfach wie möglich aber bitte nicht einfacher dargestellt werden.
Eben nicht einfacher und nur weil es kompliziert ist heißt es nicht kompliziert oder komplexe sogar heißt das halt nicht dass es falsch ist das heißt,
wenn wir aber die schriftliche sprache mit den erkenntnissen eines sprechenden denkens entwickeln wollen dann kann es aber trotzdem sein dass wir so lange unsicherheit momente wissenschaftliche zweifels,
der entstehung von wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisse selber auch schriftlich einbauen abbrüche in fragestellungen und so weiter ich bin
bin momentan an so einem kleinen schreibprojekt dran wo ich jetzt auf meiner forschungsreise beziehungsweise konferenz reise in los angeles war für zwei wochen und ich hatte mir vorgenommen hey tagebuch format das hat sich für mich bewährt ich schreibe also täglich
versuche ich das jetzt mal schreiben mir zu erschreiben was ich da mache und wie diese reise eigentlich als arbeitsinspektorat gilt oder wie sie mich ablenkt wie die
wie diese wissenschaftlichen alltag produziert und sofort und was ich jetzt in der schriftlichen kommunikation
machen kann ist ich habe nicht nur meine aufzeichnungen von den jeweiligen tagen sondern
ich setze das am besten natürlich gleich mit later dann sieht's auch ordentlich aus und ich kann abgefahrene layouts wählen ich habe so verschiedene spalten.
Spalten text spalten in denen ich schreiben kann ich habe beispielsweise eine eine spalte wo ich wo ich den den text des jeweiligen tages schreibe und dann habe ich einen so einen blog
indem ich beispielsweise zitate einfügen kann und dann habe ich so eine kommentarspalte und ich kann mich selbst kommentieren ich kann das in frage stellen ich kann sagen das ist doch unsinn an der stelle lässt sich das auch anders formulieren und ich kann,
diesen text selber in so eine dynamische interaktion treten und das selber wieder zur darstellung bringen das heißt ich kann diesen text in einer gewissen weise versuchen die anmaßung immer schon recht zu haben nur weil er als wissenschaftlicher,
zu nehmen diese anmaßung zu nehmen das heißt also genauso wie der menschlichen rede die lüge genommen werden muss immer schon menschlich zu sein nur weil sie redet.
Weil man sie einfach auch entwickeln kann mit erkenntnissen die aus der schriftlichkeit beispielsweise stammen sehr präzise zu sein sehr genau zu achten dass es nicht
kriminalisiert nicht einfach zu sagen ja das ist doch so wie wir reden
ist mir doch egal ob da jetzt die männliche oder die weibliche form steht oder so sondern man kann ja auch das einfach entwickeln in dem menschlichen sprechenden lenken selbst entwickeln dass man da diskriminierungen oder unterscheidungen einführt die die möglicherweise.
Der realität besser entsprechend.
Etwa dass man das gleiche jetzt auch für die schriftlichkeit macht die also in rechnung stellt das erkenntnis nicht ein so eindimensionaler prozess ist der dann am ende ein so ein klares ergebnis
ausspuckt sondern dass es ein prozess ist der voller geprägt ist von zweifeln von abbrechen von widersprüchen und das nicht notwendigerweise einfach auflösen kann nur weil das jetzt der forschungsbericht ist heißt das nicht dass da jetzt schluss ist,
sondern im gegenteil es könnte halt jetzt erst richtig losgehen.
Wird gerade klar dass es gegebenenfalls auch eine herausforderung für die typografie ist dass man sozusagen.
Dass unsere bisherige schrift eigentlich nur dafür geeignet ist eben diese klaren wahrheiten auszusprechen.
Überhaupt keinerlei satz regeln existieren oder setz regeln existieren wie man wie man.
Pausen abbrüche wiederholungen und zwar prinzip schreitest du hast so eine art.
So ähnlich wie so eine musikalische notstation ja so repetition ja im prinzip
mit drin hat hat man da irgendwie so seine striche und doppelt punkte und irgendwie klar und es gibt irgendwie auch symbole für lange pausen also das einzige das einzige zeichen was das in sich hat im übrigen was ich auch,
genau aus diesem grunde auch sehr sehr gerne verwende bin ich schreibe ist der.
Desch der tisch und der graphisch heißt im deutschen gibt's ja noch diesen wunderbaren begriff des gedankenstrich ja also der gedanke
strich ist halt der längste strich von allen und ich bin mir mich zumindest immer typographisch schon unterschied zu machen ob ich jetzt einen bindestrich verwende.
Was halt nur zum binden oder
falle der satz trennung eben zum trennen gedacht ist ja oder eben in diesen normalen trennungsstrich oder eben so wirklich,
weil's nichts nichts atmet so sehr wie der gedankenstrich den eben auch reinzuwerfen einfach um auch so eine zeitliche rhythmus mit in den text einbauen zu können aber da hört's dann in gewisser hinsicht auch schon auf typographen.
Da hört's dann auf und interessanterweise ja auch über wirklich jahrzehnte und jahrhunderte.
Ist das der gesamte variations spektrum wissenschaftlicher texte
also wenn sie so ein gedankenstrich verwenden dann hat man ja schon mal glück.
Der ist ja gar nicht notwendig in einem drin und es wird einfach meistens fließtext manchmal tabellen manchmal grafiken was auch immer aber im wesentlichen wird da fließtext produziert der so konventionell vom satz her so schlicht,
uninspiriert so so unkreativ limitationen reproduziert dies nicht hat
dies nicht gibt die gab es noch nie das hat zwar immer schon abwechslungsreicher wenn man sich beispielsweise eine seite des talmuds anschaut also jüdischer religiöse texte dann hat man da beispielsweise einen heiligen text der in der mitte so als text.
Und außen herum so kommentare kommentare die diesen kleinen text
kommentieren und das wurde schon immer so gesetzt und da ist der eine kommentar von rabbiner sohn so und der andere kommentar von rabbiner sohn so und die sind immer in denselben anordnungen die sind immer so um diesen text herum gesetzt und außen rum in der marginal marginalien spalte
also am rand des textes findet man dann noch einzelne von vielleicht dem ein oder anderen rabbiner so.
Die später kamen in der texte zitate hinweise kritiken und so zu diesen text in der mitte das heißt man hat einen lebendigen text
der gesetzt ist in einer art und weise die so anspruchsvoll dass sie wirklich alles nur noch,
peinlich dastehen lässt was so an wissenschaftlicher prosa so produziert wird weil weil dort
auch grafisch variations reichtum für sich beansprucht wird der schon immer möglich war aber einfach nicht ausgeschöpft ist
und jetzt geht es mir aber nicht darum also nicht nur das kann auch eine möglichkeit sein aber es geht jetzt nicht nur darum
es geht jetzt nicht nur darum zu fragen wie kann man menschliches also mündliches sprechen wie kann man mündliches sprechen
typographisch reproduzieren zum beispiel das zögern die pausen und so weiter reproduzieren es geht ja nicht nur darum wie kann ich das da gibt's ja zum beispiel.
Transkriptionen regeln also die kennt man eben aus der linguistik aus der konversation analyse beispielsweise wenn dann pausen transkribiert werden und ein punkt ist eine mikropause und drei punkte ein bisschen länger und dann wenn's
größer wird gibt man in klammern diese kunden an und so weiter kann man ja machen alles
na und man setzt das natürlich in so einer mono in so einer space von damit jedes jeder buchstabe gleich lang ist und man das auch so anordnen kann im text das gäbe es alles aber es gibt ja auch noch darüber hinaus die möglichkeit
text jetzt als eigene darstellungsform ernst zu nehmen und zu sagen was ist denn möglich was im menschlichen sprechen zu einem ich sage
fälschlicherweise menschlich aber im mündlichen sprechen nicht möglich ist also solche anordnungen die auf gleichzeitigkeit der des visuellen,
setzen was ja beim sprechen nur mit unverständlichkeit verkauft werden kann also wenn zwei leute gleichzeitig sprechen versteht man halt beide nicht mehr
beim text ist das anders ich kann mit dem auge hin und her springen ich kann aber die gleichzeitigkeit auch als information ernst nehmen da steht das auf gleicher höhe auf der seite und der satz ist noch eine frage also gedruckter text ist eine frage aber.
Text auf bildschirm ist er nochmal eine völlig andere und dann und dann haben wir noch gar nicht angefangen darüber zu sprechen was so
intermediales möglich ist wenn wir text ton bild und so weiter kombinieren also da werden dinge möglich ja über die lohnt sich auch unter der maßgabe oder unter diese frage des sprechenden denkens nochmal neu nachzudenken.
Es fällt mir auch irgendwie gerade ein es gibt ernst jan der hat auch so seine gedichte auch so grafisch teilweise notiert.
Oder eugen gomringer zum beispiel die erfinder der konkreten poesie beispielsweise wenn dann.
So texte das grafisch darstellen was was sie aussagen sollen genau also es gab all es gibt diese möglichkeiten aber wissenschaftlich ist man dann relativ
sollen wir mal konservativ vielleicht.
Das.
Nochmal so aufs sprechende denken als solches so zum schluss zu kommen.
Was dir da auch in dem prozess vielleicht noch aufgefallen ist oder wie man das so charakterisieren kann.
Wenn man so viel redet in mikrofone wie ich es auch tue.
Habe ich auch oft gemerkt dass eben dieses erkenntnis hafte dieses.
Genau in dem moment in dem ich mich jetzt gerade befinde so dieses ich weiß eigentlich noch nicht mal welche frage ich stellen soll ja also dass man dass man sich heran
tastet an an an das was man eigentlich meint es ist ja so so echtzeit ausgrabung vorgänge im im eigenen hirn wo man irgendwie versucht zu verstehen wie bin ich denn jetzt eigentlich gerade verschaltet.
Dieser prozess bei dir im pott log.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher ob das sozusagen nur deine methode ist oder das letzten endes vielleicht auch in diesem moment gerade genauso mache war es eben oft so ein so ein ein vor und zurück sein also ein interaktives suchen.
Nach dem richtigen begriff wo man immer wieder so an so einem punkt kommt und dann sagst du jetzt.
Rolle ich das alles wieder nochmal zurück irgendwie löschen delite lite.
Was kann man davon trainieren was was ist daran sozusagen eine technik die man sich die man vielleicht generell aufstellen kann die man sich erarbeiten kann und was es halt einfach nur so wie es.
Kommt hast du da irgendwelche allgemeinen dinge ableiten können wie man sich dem nähern kann.
Im besten fall keine allgemein sondern sehr konkrete dinge die man die man versuchen kann also wenn man wenn man das jetzt auf so haut tut tipps runterbrechen will dann würde ich sagen kann man.
Kann man einfach sagen einfach machen.
Wieder neu anfangen wie neu hat das reinhard götz genannt.
Immer wieder neu anfangen wie neu das ist das motto einfach machen ich verbinde das in meinen überlegungen in
im pott log schon aber auch dann jetzt so im anschluss daran eben mit diesem begriff des experimentelle oder des experimental systems du hast jetzt gerade ausgrabungen im eigenen gehirn genannt
aber bei ausgrabungen im eigenen gehirn geht man davon aus dass da was drin ist es im besten fall auch.
Ich hoffe.
Keine keine frage aber
also aber dass da sagen dass da schon die gedanken vorhanden sind sie müssen nur noch hervorgelockt werden oder man stellt sich ausgrabung ja so vor
erstmal schaufel und dann das fein werkzeug also so ein pinsel zum beispiel da wird dann noch so rum gepinselt und man am schluss ist ein ganz schöner gedanke da der war halt die ganze zeit schon da der muss sein oder so
der veredelte diamant der so raus geschliffen wird
beispielsweise die unterscheidung von rohdiamant und soweit meines erachtens die das bessere bild oder die bessere metapher ist eigentlich die des bastler
ich schließe da an an
claude stroos überlegung zum wilden denken der das wilde denken das basteln wir denken von dem ingenieur unterscheidet.
Was verrücktes meistens sind es ja oft auch ingenieure die basteln.
Und so eine ganz große leidenschaft dafür haben und ich habe den eindruck dass wenn man wenn man sich damit beschäftigt dann ist was es zu erlernen und sich immer wieder anzutrainieren gilt ist sozusagen,
der habitus einer bastler ich vergleiche das mit der situation des schiffbruch auf offener see,
weil das stellt die dramatik der notwendigkeit dieser situation gut da.
Das heißt unter chaotischen bedingungen
prekären anstellungsverhältnissen in der wissenschaft beispielsweise sind so fragen mit denen ich
mich beschäftigen muss oder aber auch prekären situationen des beruflichen alltags im weiteren es kann ja alle möglichen menschen treffen in allen möglichen situationen man ist immer schon eigentlich in der situation des schiffbrüchigen
auf hoher see treibend um sich herum nur trümmerteile und diese trümmerteile aus denen muss man sich jetzt ein floß basteln.
Ungefähr so ist dieses sprechende denken zu begreifen als eine übung immer wieder neu anfangen wie neu es gibt gar keine alternative als schiffbrüchige auf hoher see.
Keine alternative untergehen oder ich mache halt was draus und dieses ich mache halt was draus
das ist der zugang zu erlernen gilt das ist so diese diese neugier und dieses experimentelle dieser modus des experimentelle um den es geht beim sprechenden denken und wenn man sich dann mit dem sprechen und auf dieses sprechen einlässt merkt man manche dinge fügen sich zueinander
dieses teil passt zu jenem wenn ich's da anschraubt dann kann ich mich da mal schon mal besser drauf stellen und dann kann ich dieses dort anschrauben und so weiter und manchmal entwickelt sich auch so eine art spielerische leidenschaft dafür die die die dann so eine
stabilisierung zumindest für einen kurzen moment ermöglicht aber was jede bass darin auch weiß und jede experimentelle forscherin auch weiß ist.
Ständig scheitert's ständig bricht alles wieder auseinander ständig steht man wieder da oder schwimmt treibt wieder in seinen trümmerteilen da muss man mit anfangen
immer wieder anfangen wie neu und dann und dann immer wieder dieses als auch eine so ein kontinuierliche übung zu begreifen das macht ein in einer gewissen weise würde ich sagen auch
auch so ein bisschen bescheidener gegenüber diesen gefahren der anmaßung des wissenschaftlichen schreibens das dann immer auftritt mit dem hier ist mein schiff,
findet das bitte gut schau wie beeindruckend das ist mein ergebnis von wegen
die stehen auch nur da und basteln auf offener see schwimmen können nicht mal richtig schwimmen ja und am schluss steht halt da ein schiff aber wie's dahin kam sagt halt keiner was ja und am anfang ist es schmutzig und möglicherweise halt sehr gefährlich und ständig ist man verzweifelt aber das ist auch okay also sagen erkenntnisprozess sind riskante
prozesse man scheitert ständig und wenn man nicht scheitern kann dann gewinnt man keine erkenntnis sondern reproduziert ganz sicher nur etwas was schon längst bekannt war.
Wenn man nicht scheitern kann reproduziert man nur was schon bekannt war nur wenn man scheitern kann und immer wieder scheitert
hat man die chance.
Sich in der annahme nicht ganz täuschen zu müssen dass man möglicherweise auf der richtigen spur ist und zwar in dieser ganzen vorläufigkeit und vorsichtig formuliert also dieser dieses verdächtige wenn man scheitern kann dann
macht man zumindest schon mal dinge vielleicht ein bisschen richtiger als wenn man das gefühl hat da kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen.
An der stelle immer wieder grüße an christoph schlingensief der mit seinem großartigen scheitern als chance finde ich fast alles dazu gesagt hat in das in drei worten das ist schon bemerkenswert künstlerische leistung gewesen.
Ja das ist diese.
Da ist ja auch noch so was psychologisches drin so dieses nicht selbst also diese selbstüberzeugung selbstbewusstsein ja vom.
Selbstbewusstsein zum sendungsbezogen sein so dieses sendungsbezogen hat auch immer so ein bisschen sowas mit.
Mut zu tun so ja ich trau mich das jetzt und sitzt aber dann vielleicht auch voraus dass man da irgendwie so 'ne gefahr drin sieht auf der anderen seite ist mal ganz oft angehen lässt und sagt,
ja so selbstzweifel an an an dem eigenen gedanken sind auch angebracht so.
Fußball nicht angewandt auch völlig in,
also gehört eigentlich dazu man kann eigentlich gar keinen klaren gedanken fassen wenn man nicht bereit ist vorher einfach auch ein bisschen durch den nebel zu gehen weil nur dann ist die richtung auch nicht von vorneherein vorgegeben ja,
keinen klar genormten kompass der einfach immer in die richtige richtung zeigt sondern dann schafft man im prinzip auch raum für.
Überraschendes und unerwartetes und dann eben auch für diese glückstreffer für diese momente wo man irgendwie einfach so in irgendetwas hinein rennt von dem man vorher noch nicht mal ansatzweise gedacht hat dass man überhaupt da,
landen würde und ich finde das macht dann auch gespräche interessant.
Weil sie eben kein klares ziel haben so wie unser gespräch heute auch kein klares hat hier keine.
Umfangreiche outline oder so wo ich irgendwie hin wollte und gerade bei gibt es immer so ein bisschen die vermutung hier mit einem großartigen plan daherkommen würde so nee gibt's nicht weil.
Der plan selber ist der feind,
in dem moment wo man sich eine online auf den tisch legt und sagst du das ist jetzt das was ich besprechen will macht man nichts anderes als irgendwelche.
Wegpunkte festzulegen und die dann abzuhaken aber man kann halt auf auf auf auf keinen sturm und kein gewitter mehr reagieren sondern im zweifelsfall rennt man dann halt einfach direkt ins verderben
und diese dynamische anpassung ist dann halt auch das was einfach diesen gedanken raum auch überhaupt erst
ermöglicht sozusagen dass dass dass man an der stelle auch überhaupt auf punkte kommen kann ja von dem man eben voll gar nicht hat wissen können.
Dass sie sich überhaupt anbieten können.
Karl-heinz stille hat das mal in einem band zu zu zum gespräch in diesen berühmten politik und hermeneutik kolumbien
so berühmte serie von konferenzen also tagung,
workshops würde man heute wahrscheinlich eher sagen aber egal.
Hat das mal in einem text zum gespräch die freie fortführung genannt
also das gespräch zeichnet sich wenn's ein gelingendes ein echtes gespräch ist und nicht sozusagen ein gefaktes interview oder der plan ist nicht nur einfach der feind sondern der plan ist der feind des bastler oder der bastler rin.
Wenn du einen plan brauchst bevor du anfangen kannst zu basteln dann wird das nichts dann gehst du einfach unter der plan ist aber nicht der feind beispielsweise des berechnender strategen.
Und und das muss ein auch manchmal misstrauisch machen können ja also misstrauisch gegenüber plänen.
Bei berechnende strategen sind möglicherweise nicht im immer die diejenigen denen man so.
Offenen zugang zur welt oder so unterstellt sondern die haben ein klares ziel eine mission vernichte den feind und so weiter dann steht meistens im plan die freie fortführung dagegen ist so ein freies moment im gespräch selbst.
Da kann nicht vorher gesagt werden wo das hinführen soll sonst ist es kein gespräch sonst ist es nicht das zugleich,
darüber aber genau die möglichkeit dass das gespräch sich seine eigene situation schafft.
Im unterschied beispielsweise zuvor strukturierten wissenschaftlichen diskursen wo immer schon feststeht auf welche referenz theorien auf welche methoden auf welche klassiker sich
irgendwie bezogen werden muss oder in einem politischen kontexten auf welche politischen streitkräften auf welche positionen was immer schon gilt die voranarbeiten und sofort.
Das gespräch hat weil es gekennzeichnet ist durch dieses charakteristik rum der freien fortführung.
Hat das gespräch auch zugleich die möglichkeit gewisse kontexte andere kontexte in frage zu stellen zu suspendieren.
Also man suspendiert dadurch bedingungen
grenzen und so weiter und es entstehen freiräume die anders möglich sind die möglich nur werden weil sie im gespräch unter bedingungen dass der freien fortführung
haben entstehen können.
Also so ein ein raum der freiheit das gespräch schafft sich seine eigene situation und macht sich in gewisser weise temporär für die dauer des gesprächs.
Aber dann aufgezeichnet selbstverständlich darüber hinaus unabhängig,
von bestimmten dingen also sozusagen im gespräch können wir das mal annehmen.
Unter uns sozusagen in diesem gespräch.
Wir schaffen uns einen kontext der gilt der ist nur sich selbst verpflichtet und es gibt erstmal die möglichkeit vielleicht auch von so vermeintlichen denkunmöglich seiten einmal abzusehen,
paul feierabend gibt's dieses in der wieder den methoden zwang dieses berühmte buch zur methoden kritik in der wissenschaft,
gibt es so eine fußnote wo er über einen physiknobelpreisträger spricht und der wurde gefragt wie er denn zu der erkenntnis kam für dir jetzt den nobelpreis bekommen hat.
Und dann sagte der ja die bücher in denen steht dass das nicht geht hatte ich entweder nicht gelesen oder nicht verstanden dann habe ich's gemacht und es ging.
Und und das bezeichnet sehr gut was in dieser freien fortführung auch gemeint sein kann in dieser suspendierung der vermeintlichen denkunmöglich zeiten.
Entsteht im gespräch dann etwas worauf man vielleicht nie gekommen wäre weil man einfach sich auch nicht zugetraut hätte also dieses basteln der moment ist dann der einzige umgang sich da so freiräume zu schaffen.
Na das ist ja auch so ein bisschen die treibende der treibende faktor so in der hacker kultur auch immer schon so ein bisschen gewesen so dieses
mir doch egal was hier irgendein manuel behauptet oder so dass das nicht geht oder dass irgendwas unmöglich ist oder nur ein mit dem und dem aufwand zu schaffen ist generiere das jetzt einfach mal.
Und oft sind die lösungen.
Die dann trotz alledem gefunden werden auch vor allem davon geprägt dass man auch ein ganz anderer auffassung des systems hat.
Muss man sich also einfach überhaupt gar nicht schon darauf einlässt was die angeblich wissende seite meint ja.
Teilweise auch die hersteller von irgendwelchen.
Computern oder so ja oder betriebssystem die sagen ja das funktioniert ja so und so und das sind die grenzen so und halt so die hecke rin daher und sagt halt so nee mir doch erstmal egal ich schaue mir das jetzt mal von unten an und zwar nicht wie es gedacht ist was ihr meint wie es ist.
Sondern wie es geworden ist weil es ist ja auch voll mit euren fehlern euren fehler annahmen euren dingen dir übersehen habt
sachen die er selber nicht gut einschätzen könnt etcetera p p die letzten endes eine ganz andere realität darstell
und die wird dann halt aufgedröselt und man man man versteht es halt sozusagen aus der unmittelbaren betrachtung heraus und blickt
dann einfach anders auf die struktur und dann ist natürlich auch zwangsläufig dass man ganz andere werkzeuge und herangehensweisen entwickelt um eben dann mit diesem system umzugehen und stellt sich dann raus so.
Geht doch irgendwie beziehungsweise guck mal was hier noch geht das überhaupt noch gar keine haufen zeige hat man einfach eine andere gedanken struktur ermöglicht hat so.
Und dieser prozess.
Ist ja auch so ein also gerade so
mythos hacker kultur auch nicht zu selber über überhöhen aber ist ja oft auch dass man dann auch mit sich alleine ist und und und dem system also gerade so programmierer und so klar man kann sich auch absprechen und,
sehr wohl können auch gerade dialoge was bringen ist also der klassiker wenn man irgendwie auch mit dem eigenen code nicht mehr weiterkommt dann geht man einfach zu irgendjemand der davon gar nichts weiß.
Erklärt am sozusagen was gerade die situation ist die person weiß danach immer noch nicht wovon man spricht aber in dem moment wo man darüber spricht.
Wo jemand das problem was man hat gerade erklärt dann.
Versteht man auf einmal selbst was eigentlich gerade schief läuft ganz interessanter prozess in gewisser hinsicht auch eine besondere form des,
sprechenden denken wir jetzt auch gerade in diesem moment gerade erst wieder klar geworden ist dass man dadurch.
Auch einfach seinen hirn quasi neu,
formatiert so man nimmt irgendwie die daten mal kurz weg man man man schafft irgendwie erstmal so ein so ein so eine neue basis schiebt wieder alles drauf es sortiert sich alles wieder so ein bisschen anders ein und siehe da ah ja okay ja ist ja klar logisch irgendwie deswegen geht es nicht.
Aber erst in dem moment wo man's ausspricht wo man wahrscheinlich auch.
Immer ein interessanter physiologischer vorgang an der stelle auch was was eigentlich passiert also das bedeutet dass es dass ich spreche.
Lese ich meine informationen neu aus ändert sich mein hirn in dem moment wo ich es auslese.
Ja also ist das umsonst quantenfeld in gewisser hinsicht dass ich das hier sozusagen auf einmal dadurch dass ich dass ich meine mir gegebene informationslage einfach mal abrufe als sie automatisch dadurch auch wieder ändere.
Ja also von gehirn weiß ich so wenig ja da ich bin halt kein.
Frage ging auch mehr in den raum als.
Das mögen neurowissenschaft.
Ja ja.
Können sie sagen dann so sachen wie weiß ich nicht dass sie eben bestimmte wiederholungen führen zu prägungen warnung und so weiter,
aber was mich interessiert ist tatsächlich ich glaube diese überraschung
an diesem phänomen selber zeigt eigentlich nur dass wir manchmal von von vermeintlichen dingen ausgehen von dingen ausgehen die so so vielleicht nicht tragen zum beispiel eben dass das schon da ist es muss nur noch freigelegt werden,
ist vielleicht so eines ihm sprechen selber erschaffe ich überhaupt erst eine darstellung deren fehler ich dann.
Als gesprochene darstellung erkennen kann das heißt wenn du vorhin sagst ich erkläre das jemanden und.
Und und plötzlich stelle ich fest weil ich das jemanden erklären muss stelle ich fest das sind down das sind doch fehler also ich erkenne den fehler plötzlich selbst der fehler war mir vorher vermeintlich vielleicht einfach gar nicht da,
der war gar nicht da weil es gab diese darstellung nicht die fehlerhaft war also zwar hat auch das nicht funktioniert was ich machen wollte.
Aber wenn ich von einem fehler sprechen möchte oder ein irrtum auf dem
vor annahmen die auf denen dann andere dinge gebaut wurden dann setzt das voraus dass es diese vornamen und darstellungen schon gab die gab es aber nicht und er ist indem ich sie in diese startstellung hineinbringen.
Wird das zu etwas was ich wiederum modifizieren kann was wiederum fehler anfällig ist oder nicht was ich befragen kann daraufhin ob es ob es funktioniert oder nicht.
Und das macht einen entscheidenden unterschied das ist jetzt nicht nur sozusagen eine erkenntnistheoretische spitzfindig zeit
im sinne von ja ob ob das jetzt vorher so da war oder nicht ob das sprachlich dargestellt ist oder nicht das ist doch egal
klar war vorher war ich auf irgendwelche annahmen eine route meine mein mein mein tun auf und die stellten sich als falsch heraus und diese annahme hatte ich gar nicht explizit formuliert aber irgendwie habe ich sie halt mitgeschleift die kamen von irgendwoher und so weiter aber eben es macht einen unterschied
man hat diese annahme nicht mitgeschleift wenn man sie vorher nicht hatte
wenn sie nur im prinzip wann dann ist da dann sind da dinge passiert und im gehirn passieren auch ganz viele dinge aber eben nicht darstellungen die fehlerhaftigkeit sind
die fehlerhaft sind sondern erst in dem dass ich sie darstelle.
Bringe ich sie in ein zusammenhang indem ich sie daraufhin befragen kann ob sie fehlerhaft sind oder nicht ob sie funktionieren oder nicht ob das weiterhilft oder nicht,
und das ist das was ein gespräch unter anderem leistet ist genau diese darstellung das heißt nicht dass das denken etwas ist was von der darstellung in seiner durchführung.
Unterschieden ist,
es passiert nicht ein denken und dann sprechen so wie wir das lernt ja so im sinne von erst denken dann sprechen kriegt er als kind sogar gesagt ja ist halt falsch man müsste sagen ja das sprechen ist das denken.
Nicht erst denken dann sprechen.
Tschau.
Was soll man denn noch groß hinzufügen jetzt an dieser stelle also man könnte jetzt noch wahrscheinlich ein paar stunden weiter philosophieren aber das kreis ist so für meinen geschmack ganz gut ein also ich habe.
Hallo.
Zu den eindruck so generell mein es wird immer so viel debattiert gerade in der zeit so ja wir müssen nicht mehr mit fehlerkultur arbeiten müssen irgendwie so dass die.
Wir können uns nicht weiter so in so einer perfektion orientieren und.
Das drückt sich glaube ich so in diesem diskurs den man mit sich selber führen kann auch ganz gut aus man muss sozusagen seine eigene.
Seine eigenen fehler.
Iterativ permanent korrigieren und es geht zeigt sich stellt sich raus geht ganz gut indem man einfach mal mit sich selber redet.
Auch mit anderen aber aber was aber es funktioniert eben auch mit einem selbst und kanada ganz interessant diskurs gehen.
Ja moritz.
Schön trotzdem dass wir nicht ganz alleine waren sondern zu zweit.
Ja und was weiß ich wie viele millionen hörer und hörerinnen das jetzt hier auch noch mit,
eis haben was was man ja nicht podcast werden ja auch noch in fünfhundert jahren gehört also die.
Es geht immer es geht immer so weiter.
Bis dahin gibt's eine lebendige tradition an selbstgespräche podcast.
Ja ich sollte vielleicht sowas auch mal machen aber das was sollte man sich nicht vornehmen sowas sollte man einfach nur tun vielen dank moritz.
Und vielen dank fürs zuhören bei das war's jetzt hier zum jahresende hätte ich fast gesagt zum ende des jahrzehnts von mir aber natürlich nicht zum ende des podcast.
Tschüss und bis bald.